Hello the Joe rogan.net experience.
What is it?
Whatever the fuck I call it.
You know what you're listening to the Joe Rogan experience is sponsored by the
fleshlight,
the number one adult toy from men.
I use it myself.
I recommend it.
Or race dot.
Don't let people know I use it.
It's embarrassing.
Listen,
uh,
go to Joe rogan.net.
Enter in the code name Rogan on when he clicked the fleshlight link and you save
15% off.
Holla at your boy.
No buckle up bitches.
Here we go.
The Joe Rogan experience.
Yeah,
my girls back.
Jarrod,
that scary.
Take Black Guy.
He had a guy that was doing,
does
the Joe Rogan experience that voice,
but it was,
it was a white guys that sounded like a black guy.
You could tell it wasn't really a black guy.
All right.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
It was a white robot that's sounding black to Freddy Lockhart has joined us.
Ladies and gentlemen,
my man,
Freddy,
Freddy and I go back to when Freddie was fucking cover booth man at the Goddamn
comedy store,
20 years old and dreadlocks back in the days.
Freddy,
who was trying to make it happen out here in La,
a fresh faced young boy and we became friends and we've been friends ever since.
That was a fun times,
man.
I bet it was.
And now look at me now I'm an old man.
Freddie is one of those,
you know,
you know that he's got some black in them,
but how much,
how much going on here?
Let me just strip Joe Rogan.
What are your yet at Dad's black mom's wife.
Standard issue.
Pretty much powerful.
Powerful combination genetic wise,
right?
Yeah,
absolutely.
I'll go strongest combinations of all time.
I would say so,
yeah.
You get the body of the black man and then you get the mind of the white man
altogether and some strange combination.
It's why the University of Arizona won the 1996 national championship the whole
way mean that black people don't have brains.
It's a different brain.
Don't get me wrong,
but I'm saying it's clearly black people have the superior bodies,
right.
So you gotta be crazy to argue with that.
Greatest athletes of all time,
you know,
to a man,
except for a few few fucking Larry Bird's in there,
a few weird white guys that manage to figure shit out.
Right.
Other than that,
I mean,
let's get real,
you know,
they're the super athletes that we're,
we're,
we're tracking down Jimmy the Greek a territory right now.
And he was absolutely right.
It was just that,
right?
Is that right?
And you're just a Douche bag.
Yeah.
He was just a Douche bag and it was just like,
you know what?
Everything he said you couldn't disagree with it.
Right?
Yeah.
It's just,
here's my problem with it.
It's not a bad thing.
You're talking about a positive attribute.
Why is it racist to say that black people are the superior athletes?
Right?
I mean,
if you just looked at the numbers,
the number of Michael Jordan's and Lebron James is and those,
those guys,
those superior super dominant athletes,
right?
Very rarely like white guys make up what,
15% of the population American population less than that.
And they make up 90% of the NBA with a 509 in the NBA.
Calm on.
The white
guys are European,
the European.
See that's another thing Europeans like from right,
like Russians are a different fucking breed then white people here.
Oh yeah.
There's some hard motherfuckers and some serious athletes like you ever see
Carolyn the the wrestler,
it's seven foot tall,
300 plus pounds guy who would hurl grown men through the air.
Only lost once.
Okay.
And the reason why he's only fought Lou rule on gardener wrestled Rulon Gardner
and it was a new rule in Greco Roman where if you lost your grip and then had to
reattach it,
even if there was no dominance,
that guy got a point just cause he made you break your grip.
Oh Wow.
It's the stupidest rule ever.
And it was one that didn't exist through corellas entire reign.
When you want to talk about it.
Fucking so prick athletes,
they used to call him the experiment because his parents were like five,
five and five,
seven and he's fucking seven feet tall.
Any normous I mean,
he doesn't even look like a real man.
He looks like some shit from 300 right.
Looks like some shit that the Persians would have with a dog collar on.
I know naked with a fucking giant iron codpiece you know,
running at you.
He didn't rush to training in the snow.
Giant savage just eaten reindeers and shit.
That's the anomaly.
Every once in a while there is,
there is a white guy,
there's,
there's more pure European like that,
but pound for pound in America yet.
But the,
the black race is superior in sports.
Yeah.
But here's the misconception is that you're saying that they're limited to that
and that's not the case at all.
Well,
physically,
you know,
it's also you got to deal with,
it's an economic issue.
People from,
especially when you deal with people that are into like combat sports,
like the combat one,
especially if boxing,
that's a serious economic one.
Very few rich people get it.
Become professional boxers,
right?
It's,
it's always like,
it used to be the Jews in New York that was like,
you know,
Slapsie Maxie Rosenbloom.
And back in those days,
like Jews were a lot of boxers were Jews and then it became a Italians and
Irish,
Puerto Ricans and Irish.
And it was really mostly immigrants that were poor.
And then eventually,
you know,
blacks and black athletes.
Right.
But if you look at like greatest athletes of all time,
just only a few like rocky Marciano was in the mix.
A few guys that were like super dominant that were white guys.
Wayne Gretzky.
Yes.
Yeah.
But given a sport that was,
you know,
dominated by whites,
a Wayne Gretzky,
like look at their attributes.
Wet Gretzky was like very clever and an excellent skater and just,
but like rocky Marciano was known for being just ridiculously durable and,
and just always an incredible shape and would get ahold of you and eventually
wear you down a blast.
You,
so it wasn't like a Muhammad Ali where you couldn't even fuck with them.
Like you were in front of them going,
what am I doing?
Even in the ring with Roy Jones Jr,
right?
You remember when Vinny Pazienza fought Roy Jones?
There was a wound where he didn't land a punch.
It was the only time ever in Compu box history where they had Rick scored entire
round,
100% lopsided.
The other guy didn't land a single punch.
Mexican boy Jones just lit him up.
He was dancing in front of him like a Cobra.
He thought that from down here.
Yeah,
he fought for back here and that jab would come up,
slap you in the face and you're trying to move your big fat head.
You can't get out of the way of it.
Are you that guy fight night,
super ad over over Ali.
I use them in fight now he,
he's the man dude.
He had some ridiculous attributes,
but he had one fuck up.
He developed his technique,
technique based and dependent upon his physical attributes.
Instead of going with traditional technique like of like Bernard Hopkins,
Evander Holyfield guys who do everything textbook like James.
Tony does everything textbook.
Instead of doing that,
he went with this big wide open,
loose style that almost completely relied upon his physical attributes.
So when he started to slow down,
they'll start to get fucked up.
You know,
when he fought Tarver he got fucked up,
you know,
and that was he coming back from the weight loss because he fought heavyweight
and when you know he got pumped up and then he came from whatever legal or
illegal,
I don't know what the fuck he was doing,
but he got big.
Yeah,
you're going to like over 200 pounds and really muscular,
right?
And then he drops back down to one 70 and you're looking at them and you're
like,
oh,
one 75 and you're like,
okay,
something's hormonally wrong here.
His body looks soft.
You know,
I'm looking at this,
I'm like,
this is a guy who didn't do this correctly.
I bet he jacked his system.
When you,
you get on juice,
you Jack Your fucking system.
And then if you get off it,
if you're not doing it correctly,
you get off of it.
Your body doesn't bounce back.
You're not producing testosterone,
you know your,
your body is shut down because you've made it have all this extra shit in your
system.
Your balls are like,
what are we doing?
Let's stop working.
So you have to like bring your balls back to life or something like that.
Like what you're doing.
It's like really radical chemistry.
He clearly wasn't doing that right.
And he came back and he looked like really soft and he got tagged and blasted.
It was one of those things when you get blasted once,
man,
it's so much easier to get blasted again.
Cause then Glen Johnson blasted and then it looked really bad at broke.
You're cool.
And that's the thing too,
it's not just that he goes out out unconscious like that.
When the Glen Johnson fight,
he didn't even look like that big of a punch and he went completely unconscious.
One leg up in the air.
I mean he was gone,
which means he's got brain damage.
I mean that's really what it is,
you know?
And so then he like he,
it was all because of his is two things because his body coming back from being
big against Diaz at what was that?
No Ruiz big against Ruiz rather John Ruiz and then it was also the those two
knockouts.
Man,
if you have knock outs,
ma'am,
you don't,
when people,
you know they want to poo poo it like it's no big fucking deal.
You got to bounce back from that thing really slowly and really correctly.
You got to know where your fucking brains out because you might have loose
screws in there.
Oh yeah,
you can be done with it mean you could seriously have serious brain.
There's guys that they get knocked out once and then every time they get hit
afterwards they're just,
they just go worse.
Before he used to have iron chin's I'd grown up watching Mike Tyson all the time
and watching that,
that method of coming out real close to the body,
how he wouldn't just like up there.
It was,
it was like the swiftness of like when you see a bear hit somebody in their
shoulders popping all that.
But as he got older,
it was kind of like a genre specific kind of technique of boxing that there's a
little less traditional.
It seemed to,
you know,
like you said,
once somebody gets knocked out once buster Douglas,
who shouldn't have got the best of him,
but then once that,
that that's opened up that,
that,
that mess with your psyche and to top it off
if you're retarded like him already.
Do you know how tough he was,
man,
the band fucking bombs he took from Holyfield and first fight before he went out
and we got hit with everything.
Dude Holyfield was teeing off on him and he was just taking them in.
His legs would buckle up and when he finally went down and he's like searching
for his mouthpiece,
you're like,
Holy Shit here.
That's a dude who could take a page and they say,
Oh,
you took meetings with this dude took beat buster Douglas one dude.
That combination that he blasted Tyson with and Tyson still try and put his
mouthpiece back in.
That mother fucker was game to the end,
blasted out and he's just a scratch scratching around looking for his mouthpiece
to get back in his mouth because he's gonna fuck you up.
Yeah,
he's going to get up and he's gonna fuck you up.
They said that he got knocked out I think one time in a sparring match when he
was a kid like 1516 something like that.
And like he's one of those boxes that go somewhere in Christ,
you know,
and then it comes back and murders it.
Yeah,
he did that.
Apparently he did that to a w who was it?
One of his old guys out.
Let's with somebody like that.
He was training with some and the dude got the best of him in a spa and Tyson
went somewhere,
cried shepard held his knees and that came out and just drop bombs and never
looked back.
So terrifying.
A guy who needs it that much.
A guy who needs it so much is everything about him,
his entire self worth and tire self esteem is just all based on him fucking
smashing you just running out and destroying you as a human body to body.
Just imposing his fucking physical will on and they still has that.
That thing about him that I see him on sunset every once in a while and just
like,
even if you catch his eyes with you here,
just you know,
it's like,
hey,
hey Mike.
It's like that guy is just a killer bro.
He's a trained killer.
He's got the show now.
He's got another pigeon pigeon homing pigeons.
That's what he does,
right?
He like,
like they do in Brooklyn in Puerto Rico.
They home pigeons.
I guess the whole idea is you compete against Mike to really the home you're for
pigeons let him win.
I would always let him play.
He snaps your pigeons.
Next Dude,
I'll let you win.
I'd let him win at everything but,
but I,
I've said it,
I've exceeded it.
I'll take him and Mike Tyson's punch out.
I'll knock them out first round.
You mean just punch out and just punch a judge?
Just punch out now he has a new game.
I thought he spammed me,
but apparently it wasn't spam.
I got a tweet from his account and I was like,
oh my God,
Mike Tyson just fucking spam to me.
And I wrote that and Twitter and then uh,
he said it's not spam Joe.
And I'm like,
oh,
the,
the real life.
I think.
Oh Man.
I mean he might be some people that work for us.
Have we said anything bad?
No.
I mean I would never say anything bad.
I'm a huge fan.
Sorry.
Please don't Iron Mike Messiah.
Don't eat my ears.
We Love Mikey.
You want to go back to like ferocious boxers?
All those,
the time when he was a champion and there was no time like that where you like,
you were just waiting for this execution.
It wasn't a fight.
It was an execution.
You know when sugar ray Leonard was the baddest motherfucker around and like,
oh shit,
sugary lender,
they're going to have a rematch with Thomas Hearns.
You know,
like there's like,
it was exciting,
but you didn't know who was gonna win.
Right.
You knew Mike Tyson was going to victimize somebody on Hbo and you were going to
watch it.
You weren't going to pay 45 bucks or something.
Mike Tyson fight Tony tubs.
What the fuck did you think was going to add the fuck?
We know.
What's funny is my Granddad,
some old school dude love the Friday night fights and all that and was,
it wasn't with Mike Tyson it at all.
Most grandads were,
and he's like,
man,
he ain't shit.
You know,
talking about that shit.
Right.
Wait,
wait,
wait.
Larry Holmes gets a hold of him.
He got a hold of Larry Holmes,
Larry Holmes.
I think he was quoted as saying,
that man hits harder than anything I've ever felt in my life.
He was on a totally different level.
I would have loved to seen him at his very best against everybody.
Not saying he would have beaten Ali,
but man,
would that have been excited.
You can never say who can do what.
I'm privy to him because I was part of that generation,
you know,
better technical boxers.
You know,
there was better like Lennox Lewis and at his past was a better technical boxer
and he was a hard guy to crack.
He would have been interesting cause when by the time Tyson fought him,
Tyson was already older and you'd already really lost most of his motivation.
He just wasn't the same.
He was trying to get a pay day and even admitted it after the fight.
But when,
when he was younger,
man that wasn't the case.
When he was younger it was a,
it was a totally different animal that would've been,
it would have been interesting to see him at his very best.
Like in the Larry Holmes fight that was at him and his very best,
he was to destroy Michael Spinks.
Yeah,
that he was,
he would have loved to see that Guy Against Ali 21 he was at his,
I wouldn't say the apex of his talent.
It was just that at that w when a customer auto died around then when he had
one,
he hadn't slept yet.
It was flipped yet.
And then when custom auto died and you're pretty much in don king's hands,
I think that creates,
like now you have the,
you know,
one of the greatest athletes that ever lived that he killing machines.
If it's in the wrong hands and it's not fostered right,
it's going to be,
you know,
used the wrong way because I always feel like he's got a great heart.
You know what I mean?
Like he's one of these guys who you can see his emotion,
you can see him and he was just always jerked around by the wrong people,
you know?
Well that's definitely going to be the case in,
in,
in any situation where you got some powerful fucking kid that can make you a lot
of money.
They're gonna,
you know,
you're going to do whatever they want to do with you and you know,
help you in some ways and support you and you know,
make sure that you make money.
But at the end of the day,
they're just trying to,
trying to push your mic.
You mentioned how Conti Robin givens must have been there.
Married,
shut Harvard graduate with Mike Tyson member,
that fucking interview they did where she was throwing him under the bus about
how crazy he is in the violence and this is on TV and he's just sitting there
like,
Whoa,
what?
Barbara Walters,
right.
And then he's just sitting there just taking the beat.
Ben,
she's going to go out like this.
Yeah,
I could snap her.
I'm the man.
I can't believe all of the things I've done to save her life headed the class.
That's the best she had done.
He had knocked niggas out left and right and she's going to go in and drag him
under the bus delete.
She was beautiful.
She was,
no,
that's the problem.
When you get some beautiful manipulative person,
usually crazy person,
person that really wants to pretend to be something else and then get into your
life and then control it.
Like there's some sort of a fucking parasite,
you know,
put a wheel behind your neck and then really that's what she was.
Once you become the little creature in men in black who lives in your brain and
it drives that with joy sticks.
Women want to do that to powerful men is a thing that women want to do to a man
that has some semblance of success,
some some power or something where it makes him seem extraordinary.
If
she can dominate him with her pussy,
that like robs him of his extraordinary ability.
It takes us cheat like a girl that wants to fuck Francis Ford Coppola,
like to this date as bitches that try to fuck Francis Ford Coppola.
He might be eight years old or whatever.
There's some crazy hot bitch out there whose goth and she's got a fucking tattoo
of a bat above her pussy.
She wants to fuck him.
Fuck him.
She's got a chief,
says she siphoning badge and she's ready to take his all his creative.
She loved apocalypse now or was that his movie was right.
Yeah.
She wasn't loved apocalypse now and she wants to suck his dick,
the batcave,
so they're out there.
There's,
there's bitches out there that will ruin your life.
Just like there's dudes that will ruin women's lives.
You know,
it's not even a male female issue.
It's a a retard issue.
It's a broken human issue.
The people,
it's a knowing,
knowing,
having children too.
You see this so fucking clearly,
like you have a direct input on how this human being developed.
Very,
very direct.
You know,
it's a,
it's a real clear you to some good things and then they repeat those good things
and you see them hugging little girls and having fun.
You see like there's all this good energy is coming out of your kids and then
you see these fucking people that are smoking and yelling at their kid and their
kids beat,
beaten another kid with a stick.
And I'm like,
okay,
kids are little savages.
It's so clear.
It's like are what they are is bundles of potential.
But you gotta fucking rain.
The raising a human being and developing a human being is one of the most
complex and demanding tasks.
A fucking human being can undertake an end.
One of the most important because it literally the quality of the fucking
society around it is based on how well the people inside of this group are at
raising their children.
That's the number one concern.
If you are terrible at raising your children,
your children will become problems.
They're gonna break into cars.
They're going to be pains in the asses that had caused crime.
The less of those,
the more people that do a good job raising your kids,
the better.
The more people that are moral,
Or if you're an idiot,
at least yield to yourself and say,
I'm an idiot.
I'm going to make my kid not an idiot.
She's like,
how do you want to chat?
You know,
idiots don't know they're idiots,
man.
Almost every idiot thinks scary,
thinks the world's fucking them over and they really should have gotten a better
break.
You know,
whenever you hear that from a person,
look at the world fucks everybody over stupid.
Every somewhere along the line your life,
you're going to think you should've got this and it didn't happen and this
should want your way.
And it didn't all that poor me shit.
I'm like,
you know what?
Take a look.
What if you lived in Japan?
What if he looked at,
you know,
anywhere else where it's soft.
It's like get some perspective.
It's like guys will come to you with some stupid shit,
like jet amount or can't catch a break,
man.
It was this girl,
you know,
and uh,
I thought she was the one and I was ready to get married and I got the ring and
I came over a fucking apartment a day earlier and she's fucking this guy.
I can't fucking believe it bro.
I can't catch a break.
Look,
would you meet?
Can't catch up.
You just got the best break ever.
Are you almost married that crazy hooker,
right?
You were coming over there with a ring and she's sucking some other guy's cock.
You got like clear evidence that she's a skank you.
This is a time machine brow.
You're able to go into the future.
See how this would have turned out and can nip it at the bud right
here.
When did you sit?
You make yourself attorney's fees and a long lengthy process.
Yeah,
you caught an awesome break.
Yeah.
Can't catch a break.
You just can't handle your breaks.
It's all a matter of perspective.
I want everything to be perfect,
right?
It's not going to be perfect,
but you just caught a huge break.
That guy realistically,
he should shed a couple tears and then start laughing and go,
God damn,
I got offline.
Think about what have you had kids with this crazy when you weren't home with
kids and their happy meals and mom's sitting on some stuck in some cars,
the living room hoping to get it done quick before her husband comes home,
but they don't time it right and you walk in like that's how crazy that pitch
is.
Your kids are watching are sucking off some giant black fucking telephone worker
and then you have to consider this.
You have to consider what you know.
You have to consider.
Why are you attracting these kinds of chips into your life to begin with.
You know,
are you that big of a dope that you attracted some kind of trick like that?
Well,
sometimes they trick you just by being hot.
That's a real problem with dudes.
I don't know if it's the same flood warning curls being high.
It must be the same problem with girls because girls will end up with Jerky
guys.
You know those Jerky guys must just fuck the shit out of him.
That's probably what's going on there.
Like a little,
a little bit of little bit of,
you know,
some sort of a problem and their personality,
some sort of a weird disorder where they can't get someone out of their life.
They're the people that have that.
What do they call that?
Like a,
they have some kind of codependency.
Codependent issues.
Yeah.
I mean there's people that have that,
but other than that,
you've got to think I was probably fucking shit out of their shells.
It's just like I don't get people who are in these miserable fucking
relationships.
It's like I love my girl.
I love her because she's fun to kick it with and I like to hang out with her.
You know what I mean?
If I didn't like her,
I'd get rid of her.
I think here's the keys,
number one,
you like yourself,
that's huge.
And the your girl Lex herself too.
So you're,
you're both happy and as happy as you can be.
It's not like everyday we wake up,
it's like,
oh honey,
I love you so much.
I'm just like,
don't even talk to them.
Right.
It's like if you can get,
if two people can live their lives and not break each other's balls,
not,
not create drama,
that kind of thing.
I know that sounds very,
you know,
Nirvana and ideal,
right?
It's possible though,
but it is possible because I'm not asking for too much either.
You know what I mean?
You have to be,
you have to be reasonable and you have to be even in like what you expect out of
that person and you know how you,
how you deal with them too.
It's kind of who I can be.
I can be a real dick.
It's like,
you know,
we're guys,
the girl says something stupid.
You're gonna be a dick back.
Especially like if you're really struggling,
but if you're really trying to put it down and it's hard,
man you,
you get that meant that grinding mentality where you're,
you know,
you're always like trying to go,
go,
go get ahead,
get ahead,
get ahead.
And then when someone like trips that up,
I need too much attention,
I need this,
I need that.
Like it's very difficult to be considerate,
you know?
It's easy.
Like you shut the fuck up and leave me alone.
I got shit going on here.
And then you start to realize that after a few years that never serves you well
because now you've got a six hour fight instead of a two hour fun,
you know,
and you are partially to blame.
It's,
you got to step back.
I always try to fix it though.
I always stay in relationships longer because I'm like,
you know why Iceland tried to work together with some problem with anything?
Like if I was sick down the line,
what did she just going to drop me?
Because I'm sick right now.
So I always have that mentality.
So that I've
been in relationships where like ice lasted an extra year and a half and it was
just trying to fix the relationship.
Sometimes it works.
I mean people have gotten rough,
rough patches and the relationships and they pulled themselves out of it.
But it's like,
what are you accepting though?
How broken is there a person,
you know,
I can't.
And that's the thing,
I'm not in it to fix that other person.
It's like accept that and then I'll,
I'll work on the things like myself.
Like I'll,
I'll act like my dad sometimes just clam up and beat like a 1950s dickhead dad,
you know,
just reading the papers,
smoking and drinking and don't even fucking talk to me,
you know,
I'll be like that.
Then I'll have to snap myself out of it cause I'd be like,
all right,
you know,
look at it from her.
So who wants to be with this asshole?
You know?
So it's like knowing a little bit about yourself too and working on that.
Plus,
we're talking about girls that just learned to drive and like three years ago
and you know,
they,
they're still gonna have a brain that's like trying to learn how life operates
it and they'll read,
they'll take it to the mat,
they'll fight you for it.
What do you mean?
Well,
you're talking about girl,
you're dating.
Just graduated or women's.
Brian,
his girlfriend's not 20 years old.
She just turned 27 last Monday.
The Fuck Brian,
that's a woman.
That's my woman.
But I got her when she was 22.
He got her,
I got her.
I found her on my space.
I was trolling for,
for horse.
And that one found it found its way in the net.
What's the age difference?
Uh,
four years.
Four,
listen to this fucked up story because Brian was telling me this before the
podcast.
So I said,
listen,
stop.
You've got to tell me this during the podcast if you're willing to talk about
this.
So he,
he's complaining about his girlfriend,
girlfriend getting harassed.
So listen to this.
I think complaining.
I was sort of just saying it.
How funny is this?
Okay.
That,
that she's filming a movie.
And Ron,
Jeremy,
she's,
oh,
your girlfriend is a porn star.
Yeah,
but she wasn't,
this isn't a porn that she's feeling.
She's filming a horror movie.
But yeah,
everybody should know.
Uh,
but she's girl,
Girl.
So that only grow up grow.
Yeah.
So those are legit.
Uh,
so anyways,
Ron,
Jeremy is there and there,
this has happened with my ex girlfriend where like Ron Jeremy,
who also was a porn star.
Yeah.
Ron.
Jeremy came up.
It's like,
Hey,
give me a kiss on the mouth,
you know,
and she,
she didn't want a shocking,
you know,
this is crazy.
Uh,
but it's funny the second he walks in he's just like,
oh,
I didn't end of there was going to be any beautiful women there to here.
She's telling you all this.
Yeah.
She's,
she thinks she's trying to make you jealous.
No,
cause I am the one that asked about it.
I like,
did Ron Jeremy do any creepy shit?
And she goes,
well,
no.
Well yeah,
I guess he did.
You know,
I kept on trying to get it out of her.
She didn't just come up and go,
Hey Ron,
Jeremy did this.
You say creepy shit.
But that's like standard porn star behave.
What's creepy for him though,
you know?
No,
no,
no.
What's creepy is a like,
cause I've seen it in my own eyes.
What he does like with my ex girlfriend,
they were cutting a ribbon and event like it was him and her both cutting a
ribbon.
She's never met him before.
He's like putting up his arm around her and like rubbing her back and she's
like,
Whoa,
you know what the fuck you know and doing,
you know,
just very touchy feely and it's saying like whispering and in ears like you know
everyone wants to see us make out so let's do this.
And she's like,
no,
I'm not going to make out with you.
Why are you hating on his game?
That's what you do when you're running Jeremy.
Yeah,
I know.
But you're in your head.
You're to think I'm hating.
I'm just asking what did he do?
Any creepy shit?
Okay.
You were just like,
you weren't upset that he did it.
You expect that.
Not upset at all square,
almost confirming,
hey,
by the way,
we should just say,
you know,
we've labeled her a porn star.
She's very nice person,
you know,
whatever the fuck she does for living.
Brian's Brian's girls.
Very nice.
Um,
but you know,
man,
that's fucking,
it's like the Scorpion bite and the frog,
bro.
Oh No,
no.
I'm not saying my nature.
I've just,
I just wanted to hear what you would expect him to bring a boner everywhere.
He went and whip it out to like,
Hey,
you guys look boners.
And he prides himself on not using Viagara.
He doesn't give a fuck.
Oh Wow.
Was that,
don't use it.
I don't believe in it.
Yeah.
Fuck an animal.
I can't believe.
I couldn't imagine him not doing every venereal disease that's ever existed is
fighting against each other.
To the death inside his belly.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It all just duking it out.
He stays like a bed.
If he takes tests,
he has nothing.
He chose completely clean cause they're all showing each other.
It looks like the battle of Gettysburg,
herpes versus age at no antibodies necessary because the virus is just fight
themselves.
The t cells are on the sidelines laughing.
Yeah.
Everyone's going,
Jesus,
this is just an internal warfare.
If someone wins and he's got a real issue because then the host will get
attacked.
I guess I feel somewhat comforted to know he would act like that.
It's almost like finding out Michael Jordan.
I met Michael Jordan one time and he talked basketball,
any talk that openly and I was very happy about that.
I got to talk basketball.
You know,
you got to talk puss with uh,
with uh,
with a puss Smith essentially.
You know,
it's like in Ron Jeremy and it's like,
you know,
sometimes you want somebody,
he's,
he's an ambassador of what he does.
I think it's fair to say to be an ambassador.
Yeah.
You don't want Ron Jeremy.
It'd be fucking doing yoga and drinking wheat grass to be banging hose at every
bus stop.
That's what he's doing.
I actually found it awesome.
At the end of here,
right at the end of the shoot,
he comes up and goes,
so if you want to come to the rainbow room later,
I promise not to my list,
you or something like that.
You know how many times that got him?
His Dick Sucked.
Oh,
a big tide.
1 million.
There was a year ago,
uh,
there was a,
like a celebrity golf tournament that I think was Bret Michaels or one of those
guys once a year.
And every,
every hole there was like a different porn star or stripper or something in my
ex girlfriend was working like the,
the eighth hole or whatever,
this golf tournament.
And there was these two girls with them that were just total like porn stars,
like heart,
like amateur strippers slash porn starts flash escorts or whatever the fuck show
you,
whatever.
That unfortunate in tattoos.
They saw Ron,
Jeremy and the one girl just turned and guys,
I'm like,
I got to suck his dick.
And just went right over to Ron and they just started pulling down their pants
and sucking his dick right on the golf,
the golf course.
My girlfriend at the time's just taking video,
like look at this,
the city,
he had sex with her on the golf course.
I they just blow job.
But yeah,
last time you told me the story you told him that.
I don't even remember.
I thought it was fine.
I just,
I just thought it was supplemented your stories.
I want to say sex if it didn't have,
I knew that bloaty show you last time you told me he bent over and he was
banging her right there on the golf course and that's what happened.
But I remember a blowjob.
I don't either way.
That's pretty Ron.
Jeremy Being Ron.
Jeremy,
yeah,
I think it's sweet.
I think that's exactly what he has to be,
but it's just hilarious to me that,
does it seem weird to like,
what is it like dating some chick that you know all these other dudes can see
your pussy and she's going to,
I don't give a shit about that was in there and stuff.
I don't care about that as well.
It doesn't bother me at all.
What is it?
What does she,
has she been in a lot of things?
Like is it exciting?
I,
I'm an exciting,
there's something extra thrilling and it's kind of cool because like I am,
I love porn.
I love,
I love women,
women's bodies.
Cause she has a nice body.
It's not like I'm like,
yeah,
you guys can't see this to me it's like,
dude,
check this shit out.
Like people really damn it.
Celebrate porn and like know certain.
Like I've always,
I,
I love sex big time.
I just have a pretty good imagination.
I can get one out over something from eighth grade that I remember.
Right.
You know,
and in porn is always been like fishing to me.
I love fishing,
but I'm not that into watching it.
I'd rather be doing it.
Right.
You know?
Um,
but it seems now that,
that,
that porn has taken on a real,
like there's,
there,
there are actually are more than one star.
It's like,
it seems like people really make names for themselves.
She in that,
yeah.
Yeah.
That kind of known the circle.
She's a,
she's an award winner.
It's becoming more chasing little awards
and award winner eyebrows raised.
She's an award winner.
When the grab your ankles award,
you know what the biggest difference is Joe is,
is that if,
uh,
if I didn't meet her,
as a normal person and then she got into porn,
that would have been hardcore.
Oh yeah.
You'd have to deal with that.
Like if my girlfriend just one day just like,
hey,
I went start doing porn.
Ebay.
Oh,
right.
I see what you're saying.
So you expect her as she is,
when you met somebody who is already opened up Pandora's box,
you don't want to help her.
Oh dude,
this is a crazy world.
It doesn't have to make sense.
It just whatever you liked.
If you like it,
that's good you guys only together.
That's great.
There's no worries.
All that bullshit about,
you know,
worrying what other people think and other people's judgments.
It ain't going to last people.
The shit is temporary.
Temporary is fuck you.
Every body is slowly going to give out on you and you're going to be left with a
wreck of a life trying to fucking look back on it going,
why didn't I enjoy this?
I do not just have some fun and that's why none of it matters.
It's all a joke.
It's all fun.
Yeah.
If you choose to go in that direction.
If I had a Bam like a sweet by like if I worked on my body hard for like if I
was rocking Joe Rogan's body right here cause it's sweet,
I would totally be,
I would not give a shit.
I'll be starting my dick nonstop.
I would warn.
I would be doing whatever.
Who Cares?
But it's like I don't want to be the fucking Minyon.
I don't want to be like that
chicken my end and to,
these are the folks who don't know what you're talking about.
There's a website where a guy,
and we've talked about on the podcast for,
it's really ugly when he fucks all these hot chicks.
He's ugly and fat and he calls himself the minion.
What's his game?
It's just the numbers game.
Oh,
is he a pouring again?
He just pay him.
They'll fuck you.
You know what I mean?
You ever seen those a amateur ones?
There was a girl from Arizona state that got busted.
She got kicked out of school because they think,
I don't know.
I guess they have some
sort of a fucking morals clause.
You know a lot to do porn at Asu.
Yeah,
whatever it was.
I mean,
maybe,
maybe I'm reading it wrong.
Maybe she got fired from a job there.
I don't think so though.
I'm pretty sure she was a student there in any ways or maybe she lost her.
What the fuck is a story is anyway,
this poor girl,
you know,
she's just dumbed.
She got tricked next.
He knows she's doing porn and they put it up on the Internet and all her fucking
friends in school like,
oh my God,
Debbie sucking this guy's Dick.
And you know he did.
It doesn't matter what the guy looks like,
they just have this setup.
This is a lot of them.
The girl comes in,
there's cameras.
This is like most,
a lot of people's favorite,
favorite type of porns.
What does is like voyeurism?
It's like,
well it's,
it's like an interview porn.
This is what it is.
There's a guy in the room and you,
you see it from his perspective.
You don't see him ever.
So he's got like the camera on the girl walks in the room and then he starts
asking her questions while you from how old I am.
Have you ever done this before?
Now you know,
you know,
we hear for yeah.
And then,
you know,
ask them a bunch of questions.
Where'd you grow up?
Blah,
blah,
you know,
and you married,
do you have any kids?
The whole deal.
Then you have to suck some cock.
Yeah.
And then you,
you know the car,
the Guy Pulls his dick out in the girl starts sucking thing and you can see
there's like this weird fucking energy in the air because they both know that
they're doing this and it's going to get online.
Right.
You're going to do this online.
I mean,
they're not really porn stars him and he's not really a porn star and she's just
some chick who's getting talked into doing this.
I mean,
you know,
they haven't gone to vivid and worked on,
you're talking about casting couches or,
yeah,
yeah.
No.
Some of them are fake.
They,
some of,
they can't film it unless they have already done a drug test or if they've
already signed up their papers like it,
they'd every part of the country at least most at least United.
I mean it's probably thinking,
oh I bet that's the rules,
but I'm sure there's people out there gorilla and are pretty hardcore about it.
They are pretty hardcore about it.
What do you mean though?
I mean if a girl's sucks,
that guy's Dick on video.
They have to get a of it.
She has to get a drug test or tests in the whole country and the whole kind of
tell you positive about this.
Pretty positive.
I'm not,
we should restrict the least.
Okay,
let's not talk about that until we figure this out because this is a silly
conversation then because that's,
that's the main crux of the issue,
right?
I mean,
I know a lot of them are fake,
but a lot of them,
like this girl from Asu,
this Barabbas,
perfect example that's fake,
but we'll run with those are porn stars,
right?
They're not just porn starts right there at the whole,
like the whole thing.
The whole thing has been set up,
all of that one,
but not all of them.
Right.
These gorilla ones where you don't even see the guy's face.
Do you have,
there's gotta be sound.
There's a lot of ground.
If it's on a website that's making money and it's a legit website.
Okay.
Yes,
it's fake.
Where would we find this out?
Uh,
I don't know.
Make it rules will make a phone call.
Porn rules.
What would you Google
butthole,
California.
A STD test rules for taking loads on face,
on camera film,
Porn Law?
No,
Brian,
this is not true.
Porn stars could see mandatory STD testing.
Could see.
They do not have them right now.
What's the date on it is not Matt.
Matt May 11th or March,
excuse me,
March 21st,
2011 30 reshare about that.
I'm reading it right now,
Bro.
On the La Weekly Porn Stars in California with see stricter safety rules on how
they do their thing on set.
Just like construction worker has to wear a hard hat.
They might have to do dawn condoms and submit to tests.
They're saying they don't have mandatory tests yet.
From my understanding,
it's 30 been mandatory.
I don't really,
yeah.
Why are they saying this in la weekly then,
Bro?
This bitch is it telling you they're getting tested and you're just
fucking living off those tests?
I'm like,
oh cool.
I don't have aids again this week,
but la weekly's free.
They don't have any reason to lie to me.
Yeah.
I don't think la was lying.
Oh,
I know that.
That,
that what's been lately as the condom laws where they're,
they're trying to make it so I think they've already made,
it's not mandatory bro.
Here's the deal.
In porn world in la,
they already test their performance regularly,
but that hasn't stopped diseases including HIV positive scandal for one gay
performer last year.
Yeah.
It apparently it's not.
They do it,
they do it a lot,
but it doesn't seem to be like a law.
So the girl at Esu sounds real though.
I think some of my,
it is real.
I'm sure some of the followers are from Asu.
Uh,
I think there's an Asu Mckinsey followed me to find out that Asu,
there's been a few guys that are posted on our board that were,
were porn guys.
One of them,
man,
it was did just real ACC humiliation porn.
He would like,
it was really kind of depressing who would tell the stories about how he wrote
these chicks in and how like,
you know,
a lot of them were like single moms and they needed,
they needed money for the rent and how he will hook it up.
And the next thing you know they would be doing like Internet porn forum.
It's really crazy.
Yeah.
I mean I would imagine everybody recruiting,
especially for the Internet porn,
it's going to be sleazy cause you're going to go after who's weak.
It's just like a,
you know a military recruiters going to go after it.
A 17 year old.
I just combined two stories.
Again,
the guy who was the bringing in the women and and getting in,
paying for the rent and shit like that.
That wasn't a porn guy.
He was a guy who used to write stories about it and he had a website about it.
I completely confused it.
The porn guys,
that's a different story.
Damn.
Hey,
want to do that?
The stories that you really never thought about for years and there's somewhere
in the back of your head.
Then you combine them together and you're like,
wait a minute,
you guys stop moving.
Stay still.
What are you doing wearing his clothes?
You can get over there.
You know you fuckers,
you tricked me there for a second.
Let's say I get that all the time.
Or You just simply thought you made it up?
I thought I'd made,
I remember in fifth grade we buried a time capsule and our school and I was
driving the other day and I was like,
Holy Shit,
we bear to fucking time capsule.
It was a 89 I was like,
I wonder,
I wonder if they dug it up.
So I emailed the school that I went to back in 89 I was like,
Hey,
my name's pretty lock our,
yeah,
I said,
my name is Freddy Lockhart,
you know I went to school there in [inaudible] 89 I'm curious,
we buried a time capsule.
Did you guys find it?
And she's like,
funny enough we did a,
you know,
unearth it and a,
it had some water damage,
but in my mind I thought we stuck like a game boy in there.
I think what I'm doing,
it's just associating all things.
1989 we shoved in there,
but in 1989 I don't think any kid on earth would their fucking game
boy for a capsule,
a time capsule.
So I think it just was was like pictures and prices of candy bars and shit,
but I was just so compelled by just that memory popping in my head.
I got with that lady and it sounds like she's probably been there this whole
time too.
She's like,
it's always nice to hear from former students and yes we did dig it up.
I was like,
bitch,
what was the treasure in there or what?
And turns out just papers and shit.
No game boy.
I thought for sure I had a game boy in there.
It was just papers like like you know like newspapers and things of the day,
but to me it's like I,
I'm more impressed.
Like I wanted to see since of the technological revolution has gone leaps and
bounds since 1989 to now.
That's what we should have put in there.
It's like,
you know,
some outdated shit so we can laugh at it now if you ever thought about like
buying one of those off of like Amazon or Ebay or something like that,
just to see what it's like to play with it now.
What's that?
Some old gas game boy.
Oh,
I have all the elegance.
All the boxes.
I have all the storage.
Why do you think my office is so credible?
I have an old and a 10 I was telling him earlier,
there's a,
there's a show on Justin TV.
This guy,
this guy called the angry game or you've seen it?
Yeah,
it's fun.
This guy's fucking hilarious.
He says nerd.
I guess he's like in his early thirties but he reviews old video games.
It's his whole job.
He's got this whole basement Nintendo games as far as the eyes can see.
Sega Genesis Games,
you name it,
he'll review it,
but as an adult and intellectual adult who curses like a sailor,
he'll review the game and it'll take you back to when you're nine years old and
you were playing rag or something.
You like,
how the fuck do I jump over here?
He uncovers glitches and he,
and he shows you that I was right.
There wasn't a way to do that the whole time,
but I got to watch him.
This dude shit like nine episodes.
He just pissed about everything.
He's like,
no,
I'll play it on the original game.
Boy,
game fucking sucks.
He never likes anything but he voices your frustrations as a nine year old is an
adult.
That's so weird,
I think.
What is it,
the angry Gamer Gamer or if I remember.
Yeah,
fucking hilarious.
Reviewing old shit.
It's retro VI reviews though,
but that's cool.
Shit.
You know,
especially to go back and really review something from an adult perspective.
I thought it was just a dumb kid.
I was like,
I can't figure it out.
It doesn't work,
you know?
But now I realize I was a dumb kid,
but there was a click.
She as well.
Yeah.
You know,
fucking retro gaming.
It's pretty amazing.
I,
I bought something the other day on my iPad.
I'm like,
you know,
what is it like an old classic game?
And I was like,
I think this is probably the sixth time I've bought this game.
Oh yeah.
Like PAC man.
I've bought PAC man at least 20 times in my life.
Who knows how many quarters spent on an arcade version to imagine trying to
explain video games with someone in the Middle Ages.
I know it was.
Where do you even start?
Okay.
You know what,
eight bits are right.
You know how you draw pictures.
Now imagine that moving trolling,
you control it with a mouse keyboard.
Yeah.
Imagine trying to explain how to work an iPhone to somebody 10 years ago and I
think it's squinting now.
I don't want to right touch screen.
Yeah.
There was an episode of the show journeyman's.
You guys ever see that show?
Shortlived time traveling series on ABC journeymen.
I think it was like 2007 and it was really fucking good.
Of course,
I'm a time travel nerd so I was probably the only one it,
but he goes back to like 1981 and he gets shot.
He has to go seek medical attention at the hospital.
They find his iPhone laying on his chest and this doctor is like,
what the fuck?
Like scrolling through it and I loved that Shit just to see.
That's what I would time travels to go blow people's minds with shit.
Yeah.
If you showed someone a,
an iPhone just 20 years ago,
they would really,
really fucking freak out.
Spritz,
amazing how you could touch the screen and it knows like where your finger
touches,
like for letters and shit like that.
It's amazing how accurate that is.
But you know how long this shit's been out.
They'll go look like the first touchscreen phone was like sprint or somebody put
one out in 1992 and it was a,
it's an all touch screen,
like holler phone.
It was,
of course it was like 2000 bucks.
Like Google first.
Uh,
do you remember the Newton Newton?
Sure.
I remember that stupid path.
First IPAD,
my very first development deal.
I came over here and this guy who was just being executive at Disney had one and
he was,
it was showing us all in the office and we were like,
Whoa,
what the fuck is that?
And he's like,
this is a Newton.
I didn't know what that was.
Wow.
This is like 93 94 somewhere around then.
Yeah,
they did.
I'm 92 93 94 at the end.
You could email from them to,
you can fax email and all that.
That's incredible.
When I was PC only.
That's so back in the day,
man.
It really is.
It's,
it's,
it's funny when you think about it,
but it's like all that stuff.
It was they,
they knew they wanted to do that shit.
What I want to do is go blow Steve Jobs is mine and show him to shit.
He's gonna invent,
but show him when he's 20 yeah.
Right.
Yeah.
No kidding.
Look what you're going to come up with.
Yeah,
he would.
Well,
you'd probably ruined it all.
Yeah,
you would.
You'd fuck up everything in time.
If he knew that he was going to be that successful,
maybe it wouldn't work as hard.
Oh,
so in that journey,
men,
what happened is he leaves his iPhone back there and nano technology is now sped
up 30 years because he left it back in the past.
So he gets back to his profile and nanotechnology rules the world.
There's just nothing but like,
what does this journeymen,
it's called a journeymen.
It was a one season on ABC.
Fucking fantastic.
Really.
It's on Hulu.
You can catch all the episodes on Hulu and it just,
it got canceled or that canceled,
you know,
it is big budget time travel.
Small brains don't pick up,
you know,
journeymen and never even heard of it.
Yeah,
it was a short,
it's really good.
It was really good.
It was done in the way that you wanted it to be done.
Time travel.
Like they really hit the things I wanted to see.
Did they end it like they knew they were ending it or do they just end it out of
the blue?
It seems like they ended it out of the blue.
It was probably one of those things.
We went Christmas break and so it just comes up in the air.
It's over kids I was at at target the other day fucking just looking at cameras
cause it's like my little digital camera think broke.
And so I'm trying to find like a little small camera and uh,
I,
all the cameras were out of stock and because of the Japan thing.
And then I read the other day that the new iPhone is now rumored to be in
September instead of June.
Maybe because of the Japan thing.
I'm not sure that,
I'm just amazed like how much fucking shit has affected,
you know,
doesn't say nothing.
Yeah.
That's a tiny thing.
The real issue is this,
the radiations
coming out of there now,
man,
livable now.
Do you think it's,
well they've jacked it up to turnover levels seven there.
Yeah,
there that's,
you know,
they didn't think it was going to get that bad.
They said it's still not as bad as turnover because it's more contained and
Chernobyl had ash fires that burned for days and spread the shit spread the
radioactive material.
So,
but it's problematic,
man.
It's a big,
big issue and they don't know how much worse it's going to get and it's going to
keep getting earthquakes there too.
They had another one the other day.
Yeah,
a strong seven.
It never gets better.
Right.
Radiation,
you can't say it's always going to be there.
Right.
Dead Layer.
A hundred thousand years.
It's,
it'll be fucked up for so long.
Fucking Asians are going to actually have tentacles coming out of them at the
idea that we have this,
I mean,
nuclear power is one of the all time craziest ideas and everybody was like
nuclear power seats.
It's one of these things.
He's fucking tie wearing Republican cunt bags.
These assholes that are always like,
hey,
what's the alarm?
What we'll do?
You alarmists these liberals.
Swana listen,
there's nothing wrong with nuclear power.
Nuclear power is clean.
It's safe like outside of three mile island and Chernobyl.
Where's the problems?
We've had nuclear power for 30 years.
30 years is a goddamn blink of an eye.
It's this,
it's nothing.
If human beings are going to exist in the future,
thousands and thousands of years from now,
what are we going to keep piling up these fucking toxic rods until we have one
part of the globe.
Globe where you couldn't even fly over it in a plane or you're fucking plane
will melt and everyone would die of cancer.
The fuck you gonna do?
How are you going to store all that shit?
I mean they did this thing in Sweden.
I think it is.
Whether it's they have a tunnel,
it's like goes deep into the earth in this vault.
They created that.
It lasts a hundred thousand years just to keep these fucking things in it.
She's,
that's ridiculous.
I mean the idea of splitting atoms to light homes though and harnessing it and
their man think that we can control splitting out.
It was like,
oh,
but what's the options?
You look at the grid,
look at like fly over la and look at the size of that fucking grid.
Look at all those goddamn lights.
Look at all those houses.
Look at it.
It's insane how big it is.
Don't you think it should be mandatory solar collector roofs or something like
that?
Should be fucking for California.
A hundred percent man for,
well it's the problem is it's really expensive.
You know people can barely afford to put gas in our tank right now.
I mean now gas is four 24 regular.
I saw that yesterday.
I was like,
what the fuck is that for 20 for regular?
I'm like,
that's incredible.
90 bucks filling my tank the other day too.
That's,
that's wrong.
What do you drive?
You know,
Ford Edge,
these fucking cunts that we have run in this country,
man,
there was a,
there was a story that Matt Taibbi wrote for Rolling Stone about the,
uh,
I put it on my Twitter earlier today because somebody,
somebody retweeted it or somebody sent it to me and I retweeted it and it is
mind boggling and it's all about the wives of bankers getting these,
uh,
it's,
the rolling stone article is called the real housewives,
a Wall Street.
And it's about these wives of these fucking bankers getting these $250 million
loans.
It's incredible.
This,
this,
the story will make your fucking blood boil.
They've tapped into the money that was supposed to be a for the bailout and the
bailout provided a bunch of different loan options and it was basically to,
to,
to re stimulate the economy.
These fucking multi-multi multimillionaire bankers saw this opening in the
system and capitalized on it.
Dude,
it's terrifying.
And the way these,
these,
these bonds and these,
uh,
these things work is a,
they buy up sketchy bonds and if the bonds fail,
if everything fails,
they don't have to pay the money back.
But if the profit,
they make money off of it and we got the whole thing,
it's mind boggling.
It's,
it's so scary.
It's crazy.
I mean,
it's like,
it's not admirable.
That's almost crazy how you see the second son comes,
somebody finds a way to exploit it.
You know what I mean?
Somebody find some loophole in there in shame on Obama's entire administration
and Bushes,
all these curtains for not putting some literature in,
in that document saying that you cannot,
you know,
no,
nope.
No profits should be made off this,
you know,
from the bankers or the pancreas wives,
250 million.
Well that's,
that's one thing,
but how about there should be no fucking did.
The bailout is the way they've structured it is completely insane.
It's like free money.
There's no accountability.
They can can't account for the money.
We're not getting receipts either.
When it's not like the United States citizens have paid the taxes towards this,
get to review where the money went.
So there's more like an an account of it.
So you can watch it and track it.
No,
you can't man.
They don't know where the fuck it's going.
It's the whole thing is complete,
utter chaos and it's completely out of line.
These people are getting giant bonuses,
man,
they're,
they're banks failed and they got bonus.
So they get,
but they get to the rich get richer and the money comes directly from the
taxpayer.
There is no money.
The bank has failed.
They don't have any money.
So they get an infusion of money from the federal government and then they have
to pay these guys money.
These guys millions and millions of dollars and it's amazing that Obama gets
away with this,
but all of them get away with this.
You are supposed to be the fucking president.
You asshole.
You're supposed to be protecting people from this shit.
We're not.
This is not supposed to have ever happened.
And when this does happen,
you're the one who's supposed to be us.
You're the one who's supposed to step in and say,
what the fuck man,
you're Obama,
you're,
you're 46 years old,
man.
You're only a few years older than me.
You're a few years old and you're,
you're my friend.
You're in there with these fucking constant,
you're not saying it's shit.
You letting these guys steal money.
You're letting him steal billions and crushed the economy and continue to do
business as usual.
And the banks get bigger and bigger because they fucking buy up these other
failing banks and then they become even more untouchable in American cities.
But decay like Detroit and what they helped you get in power.
So that's what's up.
Like what is his name?
Are you going to wait when you get out or you're going to tell us what's up?
What happens then?
Is he going to get maybe loses this year Newt Gingrich twins and he tells us
exactly how the fucking world works,
you know,
like that.
Is that going to happen?
The please?
Got It.
And just like any other aspiring man of anybody running for president,
I don't really think it's been since Kennedy or someone like that,
who's really in it for political reasons and,
and even Kennedy was born for it,
you know,
he was groomed for it.
He was of the pedigree.
But the thing is like I now,
it's a corporate,
it's a CEO job.
You're not,
you're,
you're the top of the company now.
You're not,
like you said,
a man of the people for the people,
by the people.
And he might've gone into that thing thinking he could be,
but once you sit down and they sit you in that room,
look,
boy,
you're the puppet.
Do you think that's true though?
Or do you think it's just all bullshit?
He has any power and I don't think it's any worse than it's ever been ever.
I think,
I think everybody,
it gets up in arms.
It's like,
look at Nixon,
look at all those guys.
Everybody was,
how could you not be president and start to develop some grandiose ideas.
Yeah,
but dude,
you gotta it's financially,
it's never been this way.
It's never been with the deregulation that was passed during the Reagan
administration and continued all through Clinton and Bush and all this,
that is allowed these financial institutions to get into a position that we were
supposed to be protected from after the Great Depression,
after the Great Depression,
they put all sorts of laws in place so that banks couldn't get risky with your
money and do crazy shit and then wind up losing everything right,
which they did.
They got rid of all that shit.
They get rid of all that shit and then unchecked growth and spending came
because of that and these guys,
these motherfuckers took all kinds of crazy chances with people's money and then
it all fell apart and then banks collapsed and people lost their life savings.
What's happening?
It's happening too,
like you look now,
the cell phone companies are narrowing down to two.
There's virtually two banks.
That's not that bad though.
No one's getting ripped off this,
this,
this financial institution.
They went,
what happened with the market is a goddamn heist.
It's a giant heist.
People made millions of dollars in front of everyone's face after the banks
failed and Obama didn't do a damn thing.
It's a heist saw it.
He knows it.
It went on in the 80s to the Lincoln savings and loan scandal,
and he never liked this.
This is the biggest one by far,
ever that's ever been perpetrated by these people like fraud.
The whole thing is fraudulent.
The whole thing is a scam.
The,
from the very beginning,
they,
they knew everything was illegitimate.
They knew what they were doing was wrong.
They were trying to offering clients,
uh,
luck stocks that they knew that they were betting against.
They were betting against these stocks and get there.
We're offering up to their clients.
The whole thing is sickening,
man.
It's sickening.
And Obama ain't doing shit.
He's not saying anything.
He's not doing anything.
He's not freaking out.
It's sick.
And I don't think he can't.
I don't think he will.
I mean,
why he doesn't want to lose this job.
He's going to.
And all those people,
you know,
they help you get elected.
I know,
but being to do what?
What are you gonna do?
You a you hold,
are you the holding of barbarians back at the gate?
I mean there's so many spears and swords comes from Greg gave you,
you're just barely keeping us alive.
Think he's doing that.
I think you are.
Here's the idea of being president to get your presidential library built,
whether you serve for eight years and to sell your book and to get your deal,
you know,
and to say that you did that in politics because I bet you George W.
Bush has having a dandy all life now and a good old time.
Hey Brian,
people get real distracted when you start wandering off when we're having
conversations.
I'm actually just trying to fix that
lag that everyone's talking about right now.
Fix Lag.
Ustream is just being itself.
It's just not that spectacular.
Yeah,
I did catch up,
uh,
the,
the Charlie Sheen Ustream,
but it wasn't,
it wasn't the first one was rented to the sleep bad and he had like all his
cronies and you realize,
wow,
this is why that guy,
I hadn't heard that name since 1996 who is one of the dudes who was hanging out
with Charlie Sheen in that first use?
Treme set.
The guy from Duran Duran,
he was at the TVB Bj and there was some,
some scandal happened.
I can't remember what said something.
Put the Kibosh on his fledgling career.
Really?
Yeah.
It's something to come on.
Porn man I think involve porn porn man show you like the naked Niccolo Simon
Rex.
I don't remember him.
So he was one of the ones that was one of the hangers on and then you can tell
like the other day looked like some out of work jazz musician.
It's like you can tell like now,
dude was geeking off of drugs and I don't think he was on him,
but I think he was geeking off of him and his judgment was super suspect are not
already.
So I think he was also swimming and all the love that he was getting from all
these people winning was all over Twitter.
He had over a million followers almost instantly.
And I think he's like,
I'm the fucking shit.
Right?
But I told you these fucking trolls,
they're gonna,
they're gonna wish they didn't get rid of me.
You know,
I'll,
you know,
I'm going to have the public will demand that I come back.
But man,
you,
that's a,
you're,
you're going out there on some fucking thin branches,
son.
It's,
it's very hard for a guy like him.
Uh,
you know,
to take that Howard Beale kind of zeal that he was taking,
because at the end of the day is,
you know,
Howard bill had a lot to say,
whereas Charlie Sheen has a lot of bumper stickers,
a lot of catch phrases,
and that's fine.
But as you're seeing as you go out there,
this thing's petering on fumes now and you're starting to realize out Baldwin
did a,
an op ed piece I think like in the huffpost or something or a direct letter to
him being like,
quit being a douchebag.
Alec Baldwin.
And he's like,
here's the thing,
you're going against Douche bags and you're acting like when you're going to
lose,
you don't,
don't fight the network.
Just just apologize.
Go back.
And I was like,
well you know it apparently Alec Baldwin said he acted like Charlie Sheen during
the,
uh,
the hunt for Red October.
We're supposed to be a whole bunch of movies for him and he didn't get him cause
he was getting all like that to like bigger than the production.
Oh really?
But you know,
at the end of the day,
if this thing turned out to be a hoax,
I would say Charlie Sheen's fucking brilliant,
but he's not brilliant enough to pull off this house.
This is,
you know,
this is for real and this is sad.
And it's a guy who I haven't been sad once watching him.
I've been enjoying the shit out of it.
I can't,
I can't watch those fucking videos where they show you how they kill pigs.
You know how they know how they,
you know,
I can't watch those.
I have ignored me the whole entire thing I have now.
I've watched a couple of seconds when we talked about it,
will that and that one podcast.
I see,
I'm very into it.
I'm not,
again,
a fascinating,
something happens like a lot of people,
there's,
there's people,
something like that will happen.
And then there's the whole sector that people were like,
well,
you know,
screw Charlie Sheen.
Don't,
don't watch him.
It's like,
yeah,
I'm gonna Watch him.
It's the flavor of the day.
It's fun.
It's interesting.
This man's falling down.
I like it.
I think it's fun.
I think it's a lot of,
I don't think it's good.
It's definitely not.
I mean,
I wouldn't go,
maybe I would go to the live show for like 10 minutes.
I would,
if they put it online,
I would watch it.
I'd watch the video of it,
how strange it was.
If it was somebody else,
maybe I just never got into Shane.
I was like,
wow,
I liked hot shots.
I don't think that's about it.
I just want street Wall Street.
Gordon Gecko.
Well,
that was a long time.
Tunes [inaudible] 87 and 86 a tune.
Best Picture.
87 nominated,
best picture Wall Street.
He said the guy had a legit,
the little run there for a while.
Do you remember that movie?
Was it invasion or something like that?
Alien invasion with the fucking sixish.
Yeah,
with that black kid and watch it on a higher plane from New York.
Solid fucking Saifai flick.
I was turned on to that by Dave Foley.
Well do a news radio together and he gave back from the weekend with a big smile
on his face.
He goes,
I saw a really good scifi movie and he told me,
was this one that I got,
that movie's good.
He's like,
yeah,
what's it called?
Was an alien invasion.
I don't even remember what you're talking about.
Invasion that people,
I think it's 1996 it was about black kid and him.
That narrows it down,
but I watched it on a plane and I think I watched it on a plane from West
Virginia to Phoenix,
Arizona.
I saw tron the other day.
Finally,
3-d watched most of ad and what you know the CGI with.
Completely horrible for that.
For that dude.
There's been way better than movies with better to CGI.
I think I saw your tweet when you're about to get into it.
Some wine,
some weed and tron.
Yeah.
I didn't see the after a Simon wrecks in 1993 at age 19 appeared solo in scenes
for three masturbation porn filmed arrival.
Oh,
that's where it came to the surface after he started to get a name for himself.
Yeah.
Yeah,
but the,
the CGI,
what's his name?
Joe.
Dirt and nasty.
Simon rex is dirt nasties that,
are they the same guy?
No.
Why is your photo?
The photo on Wiki is so wonky.
Wiki,
so crazy,
man.
See that's that dirt nasty dude.
It is dirt nasty dude.
That's his website.
Dirt nasty means nasty.
Is Simon Rex could be here,
man.
I'm sure somebody out there nasty.
It was like a rapper or something.
I thought he is the same guy.
Yeah,
I think it is.
Cause Sutton wex is kind of like a wicker type,
you know?
Uh,
makes sense.
Um,
so yeah.
The CGI,
was it Jeff Goldbloom that's in the movie where they have like a younger version
of him.
Jeff Goldblum.
Is that his name?
Yeah.
That was so awful though.
Oh wait,
no,
no.
Nasty is a moniker employed by Simon Rex.
Wow.
Dirt Nastia Simon.
Right?
That's crazy.
Don't know either of them.
I'm sorry.
He is a dirt nasty.
Has One song that's pretty fucking funny on Youtube.
He's got some good songs,
man.
He was a VJ,
right on MTV.
That's,
I guess I don't know him from that.
I only know him from dirty recently from dirt nasty from some of his songs.
Some people on my,
a message board,
uh,
threw up some of the clips on Youtube.
I fucking funny man.
That's comedy.
Yeah,
it's like comedy,
comedy,
rap.
That makes sense.
Because I think he did refer to him as dirt nasty in that first early shit.
They're fucking pretty good man.
It's funny stuff man.
I enjoyed it.
Like in there,
the ramps are pretty cool.
It's like funny.
It's just you just rapping about partying.
But this,
this Charlie Sheen thing,
we saw our boy Kurt Fox through the Charlie Sheen thing.
He was that he did do the Charlie with that.
He was the guy who,
but we know the guy who went up and Detroit and bombed and everybody was booing.
We know that guy.
That's a tough go.
How many people do you think were there and I didn't feel bad for him.
That's part of life,
Bro.
You want to go out and do that?
That's what you get.
Things happen.
I guess that's what you're asking for.
You're asking to be a part of the circus.
Okay.
Someone's gotta be the Monkey.
Stupid.
I saw an article that says that Dennis Quaid wants to open for Charlie Sheen.
What?
That's a private tour
once Dennis Quaid and do what?
I've just be crazy.
I guess just as played the actor Randy.
Randy Quaid.
Sorry.
Sorry,
Dennis,
please.
1980 put up.
Pull up.
1980 dirt nasty.
I can pull it up on,
on Youtube.
I hate that Randy Quaid guy.
Yeah,
he's weird.
Shit fucked up,
but I like them if in national Lampoon's Christmas vacation,
his cousin Eddie.
That's brilliant.
You Serious Clark?
yeah,
it's good man.
You're going to like this.
Is this a rap video?
Yeah.
It's a rap video and it's,
tell me when you're going to play it because I like playing saint ready.
These are the chosen few selecting youth.
These are the ones that shine upon nine meridian with the fourth level of
government or,
and then the,
the physical vision.
Now we charge these in a studio right now for the first,
and he's like wrapping this intertwined my mind upon Bondai nine caliber Russian
roulette,
stamina,
Thailand off lift the fast track of the anomaly.
That's preposterous.
Mine.
Yep.
Well it's a bet at first towards the Wah Wah.
Shut the fuck up man.
What's wrong with you?
It would nothing,
man.
You know,
I've been doing good.
Quit smoking weed.
You know,
I've been doing some yoga,
a little polite.
He's just getting more in tune with myself,
you know,
getting in touch with mind,
spirit and body.
That bitch take ahead of this and kicked that out.
Doubt Nasty Shit about getting your Dick sucked.
It sounds like phase on love party friends.
Got It.
Well it looks like the guy that was married to Jessica Simpson.
Nick,
Nick.
Like what?
Yeah,
this is good.
I like this song,
man.
It's silly.
All right.
I like it.
Spread twin to decide one drink.
Foss
box strike
pockets.
Right?
A brand new man and I'm doing dog
brings light for me.
I think this is a funny man
and shit was crazy.
Everybody wanted to know my name.
Bringed up pain and pops shop ever go one whole my
chain when I fucked it cranks out all the bus.
I got a gold chain among cocaine.
I think I've heard that before,
but I like it man.
I think it's funny.
It's funny.
I thought it was good.
Three Po Peri Sylville [inaudible] of John La.
Yeah,
I think John's better than that though.
John's hilarious.
Yeah.
John's got some great shit.
I mean,
this is,
I don't know how many other songs he's got,
but yeah,
this was his,
uh,
this is his debut.
That's funny.
I didn't even know he was hearing that.
I need to start watching this.
Charlie,
Shane,
Shane.
Oh,
well this guy,
I don't know what he does with them.
I don't know if he wraps.
What does he do?
Does he do that?
I don't know if he goes down the road with him.
I just remember he was on the very first song songs hilarious that would,
you know,
and have the video playing in the background and that would keep the crowd from
booming.
Yeah.
Maybe they could close with it,
you know,
I dunno.
It's just,
I dunno always in New York last or this week,
this weekend.
Right.
I heard he did.
Charlie Sheen,
you,
he was in New York,
the Charlie Sheen report.
We're following him like he's fucking bigfoot.
It's working scene in New York.
Uh,
and it's working.
I mean,
his whole mission,
you know,
sort of doing something city to city,
it seems to be getting different reviews.
But this isn't new.
This isn't.
Now a lot of celebrities are doing this thing going on on tour and not being
comedians.
Who else?
Who else is doing that?
Um,
or have little experience in comedy?
Steevo uh,
he's,
he's selling out.
He's headlining.
Yeah.
He's doing a stand up though.
Right?
That's creative.
I like him and I'm friends with them and that guy has actually taken the time
to,
he really likes comedy and wants to do it,
whereas he's just been given a lot early on because he's already famous.
You know,
he's headlining clubs,
but I think he's finding that's hard a way to fill it.
Yeah.
That's real hard to get thrown in you.
That's how Charlie Murphy did it.
Charlie Murphy was famous and then he was headlining.
Yeah,
you hit the boom,
you hit it hard because you're realizing being famous doesn't supplement.
No experience being an open miker in front of a giant group of people that just
paid to see you famous.
It's too much.
Too soon.
Yeah.
Fuck yeah,
it is.
You know,
and,
but you know,
it's Charlie's fault for just diving in there and,
and you know,
and wanting to be a headliner.
I saw that clip of him walking off the stage,
Karen up the check,
walking up,
walking away
like that.
And I'm like,
you know,
I see like some Justin,
you know the thing like with Kirk and all that.
But then I see guys like bill burr who taken audience and turn it around for a
scale.
Veterans.
Yeah.
And I can't say anybody like should be that good.
But the thing is,
it's like a real skill would be to now get them back on your side.
Yeah,
yeah man.
I know what you're talking about.
I mean,
it's the hardest thing in the world.
You're going to go to Detroit where it's already tough times there and they took
your money.
That's why then you got no show for them.
You're just kind of like taking,
they're not gonna take that shit.
Detroit.
This is experiment,
you know like I understand it's an experiment,
but when you're fucking sell it on giant auditoriums like that,
you got to really,
you want to come fuck you're saying where does he go with this though?
I don't think he can keep doing it.
I think eventually people are going to like wear thin of it and he's going to
wear thin of it too.
Like he wanted to be loved and then all of a sudden half the places where he's
going,
he's getting booed and people are shitting on them and who's got the world's
attention and nothing to say,
yeah I hate and this
is not,
I mean even if he does have something to say,
like he did this one weird video were talked into the camera and he read all
this shit that he wrote.
It was like,
really?
You like produced and written and then speech kind of moving on and you know,
and he was talking like,
like hunter s Thompson.
Exactly,
exactly.
And he was like,
it was,
he was doing like,
yeah,
I mean he even said,
he was like,
he held up,
his fucking is the ticket for this thing.
He's talking about the ticket and he was doing like a commercial for it.
Buy The ticket,
take the ride and like use the hunter s Thompson line did the,
the whole idea behind it is very strange.
This guy who's this huge,
huge multimillionaire,
super celebrity and we are fascinated with him losing his job and he's trying to
campaign to get his job back and we're paying money to see him talk.
Right.
I heard it best describe a lady said,
I read an article,
it said,
we're so fascinated with Charlie sheen cause the guy,
how can a guy have so much more than us have so much less than half.
That's a great way to get best summation of that guy.
He does.
It's like,
you know,
he's loaded but he's not.
He's got,
he got no marbles.
You know,
I'll keep my marbles.
I do.
It's gone.
You're not good.
Gone Marketable God.
And like I said,
now you're trying to go the folk hero route.
You're trying to go the Conan O'Brien wrap,
but Conan O'brien's beloved because he put that much work into being beloved.
You know what I mean?
Here's a perfect example.
When he did his show,
he would go on the road,
he had a show and he's an entertainer.
And the thing is,
it's like now he's,
he's big enough.
He can go straight to the people and say,
you're not fuck the network.
People love me.
Sure.
But I've been doing this since 93 every single fucking night.
Charlie Sheen just started this,
you know,
it.
Good luck with that.
I think he fizzles out.
If,
if what's his name,
wanted to have Conan O'brien wanted to,
he could do arenas all over the country and he would do like,
he would be in Detroit one night and do a show with no television whatsoever and
higher comics and higher,
you know,
have people come on,
have musicians play and do the Conan O'brien show like a say a 90 minute show.
And he could do it all over the country and make fucking ridiculous amounts of
money about a guy who had a real grievances with the neck.
You know what I mean?
And never really aired them in a distasteful way yet.
All that whole thing is so hard to fucking really figure out.
I mean cause Jay Leno,
they kept wanting to get rid of Jay Leno and Jaylin was number one.
Like why did that,
why would they want to get rid of whole thing was really ass handed.
The way they did it was so dumb and really Conan O'brien was better in the later
night.
I thought so too.
They should have done,
I mean everybody wants the tonight show,
but I'll tell you what the Conan O'brien show was his fucking show man.
It was his show.
It was his,
there was a whole culture behind it.
And the thing is,
it's like the tonight show,
you almost need to be a lot more generic like Jay Leno to appeal to the masses.
But there was a,
there was,
this is our thing,
when you watch Conan late night,
you know,
when I see someone wanting to leave their job and go to another job,
you know that's an early,
I mean I get the fact that more people are going to be watching earlier.
I get that,
but what I would it says to me is that guy didn't get enough respect.
He didn't get enough appreciation from the network.
There wasn't,
they weren't like in behind him enough in his eyes and feel equal.
You
know,
he wanted that other job,
that other jobs,
the big job,
big job,
right about that big job.
Right.
You know when you're fucking Conan O'brien,
man with differences make of you shows on at 10 or if it's on an 11 Conan
O'brien
watches TV live.
Exactly.
I mean,
yeah,
you're not,
some people are going to miss it because they're going to go to bed early.
So fucking what?
Plenty of people are going to watch it.
All right.
Just just be,
you just be with a left.
Apparently over at CVS,
they're like,
if he gets ratings like this,
he'll stay on forever.
Life at TBS,
you get 2 million ratings or 2 million periods.
You're fucking hit.
I went from being a big Conan fan to having,
I've watched it once on TV.
I haven't watched it.
I didn't watch it when you did the tonight show.
I haven't watched since he left New York.
Yeah.
Not that I'm against them.
It's just that routine has gone better now.
Is it worth,
I don't think so.
I think,
I think the reason why I don't watch it,
cause th the late night shows what I liked.
I liked that that extra masturbating,
masturbating,
bear writers were all funny on that show.
They'd come out and do [inaudible] you know at the same writers.
I don't see those two guys.
He sees these two guys all the time.
The preparation h Raymond Guy.
Right.
Who had come out and hand up around.
I said,
yeah,
he kind of looks like Ryan O'Neal,
the comedian and then there was another one with the curly like Simon and
Garfunkel.
Fro.
Yeah,
I think they're both still around.
Those guys were like almost funnier than Conant to me,
but there was that whole New York vibe that it just as missing to me.
But I don't know.
I think the vibe is different because it's in Los Angeles.
It might be,
but the thing is I,
I can't speak intelligently about it cause I don't watch it.
You know,
I watched Conan from 93 to 2003 mostly because at first I was a teenager and
then I looked in Hollywood.
I didn't have cable at the time.
It was something to fall asleep too.
There's definitely a different funny vibe on the east coast and there isn't a
west coast.
I find even my sets are different on the east coast and they're on the west
coast.
I find I have to explain less on the east coast and I can go off into more
obscure references and not in a way like super obscure it,
but in the way that everybody's following along and I don't have to make sure
somebody needs to catch up,
you know?
I think,
I mean there's intelligent people everywhere,
but there's more of them,
these coast.
Sure.
I mean,
that's where all our finest institutions are.
You know,
it's no accident that,
that all our best colleges are on the east coast finest institution.
Ah,
yes.
Harvard.
So she'd have a cigar in your hand when you say that.
So I did sound like a real ass,
and I ask God as well,
all of our finest institutions haven't really addicted to camel to lately.
I think when,
when the Conan left,
I started watching Kimmel and now I'm like,
I don't know.
Once you go Kamilah you can't really go,
yeah,
here's a fun show.
I've got a fun zoo of a show too.
I did that show and I think it was the first,
the second comedian on there and I,
oh right.
I heard nightmare stories when they first started,
how hard it was.
Like the stage was catty corner to the audience.
It was new.
Nobody knew who he was.
They were like,
you're going to go out there and you're gonna die kid.
Bobcat Goldthwait was the director at the time and I was like,
Oh man,
oh,
this is scary.
And I went out,
it went really good.
And he's like,
man,
you're the best comic we've had on.
I'm like,
how many head on?
He's like,
one.
I was like,
oh well who is the other comp I,
and I don't even remember the other comic was,
but I don't think it was anybody,
you know,
cause I wasn't anybody.
So that's who they were picking out at the time.
But I think Dave Ras saw me at the Improv on a Wednesday night doing the open
mic.
I was 23.
He's like,
Hey,
we want to,
you want to do the Jimmy Kimmel show tonight?
I'm like,
I guess,
sure.
What's that?
Wow.
And uh,
I,
and he got me on.
So wherever day of wrath is like forever,
owe him my first,
uh,
TV.
Great.
It's good man.
He's a very good guy.
Very good guy.
He's one of those guys have been around forever.
The comedy business is such a weird fucking business,
isn't it?
And we were talking about sleazy and agents and managers and you know,
we were talking about what it's like to have one that sucks and it's weird.
It's a weird thing to,
it's like in this business it's like you can have all this drive but you have
to,
it's almost like being in a band.
You need somebody else to champion that drive as well.
Like I love music,
but I never wanted to be in a band because I don't want to have to rely on the
lazy bass player or the coke head drummer.
You know?
It's like I want this thing to happen.
And you know when you've got a team working for you like that and they're not on
board,
you're like son of a,
yeah,
that's a reoccurring theme with comics.
You gotta make sure you've got a manager that knows what the fuck is going on
and if you get a bad one,
he gets some idiot.
You get attached to one.
I have a bunch of friends that started out with one manager and then somewhere
along the line,
you know,
this a manager,
when some critical decision was to be made,
this manager fucked up and they got rid of them and they moved on and got some
bigger manager and then they got sued and a bunch of stupid shit happen.
I mean you start off with one guy and that guy turns out to suck and you know
you're attached that fucking idiot.
Right.
And he feels like he deserves a percentage of your profits.
Then it becomes like a marriage and store and then you have to break up with
this person.
Yeah,
exactly.
Just such a nightmare.
Like I had been my manager six years and I had to break up and she was very
receptive and understanding about it,
you know?
And that made me think in my mind like,
Oh man,
this,
it didn't go as bad as I thought it would.
And then you start thinking,
I should've done it sooner and all that.
But it's just like,
you know,
whatever happens,
happens.
But you can't stay with somebody who doesn't have your best interests at heart.
You know,
it's,
it's that usually cause they'd have a better client now they have a better,
bigger fish to fry and you know,
I get it in this town.
That's,
that's the truth.
My agent,
you know,
represents like Jamie Foxx and all these people.
If they don't,
if they turn it down then maybe I'll get an audition for it.
He want to make sure that you're a real moneymaker before they put any interest
in time and deal.
You've got to go out and it's almost like they have you in the stable and then
you got to go out and make your own shit happen.
Yeah,
call us and we'll take the 10% when you booked out and then,
then they go,
okay,
now let's make it bigger.
Yeah.
But like getting Christmas presents from Jews.
I mean they're,
the best thing they can do is just get you in front of someone where you can
perform.
You know,
especially if you're trying it,
you're out there trying to do the acting thing.
Man,
what a crazy job that is going to go in some fucking room and pretend that this
guy that you're sitting there with a piece of paper in his hand,
pretend that this is your brother and you guys are,
you know,
back at home and dad just got back from the war and he's a little shell shocked.
Really going to do this right here.
We'll do this in this office.
I had an acting teacher like that who always wanted to,
w w wanted to.
He's one of these super stranger.
It was the Meisner technique,
you know the real like a method to kind of stuff and he,
his whole goal was to make you cry and he would be like,
what?
What happened to your mother got killed in a car accident?
Oh Geez.
Awful Shit to say,
dude.
Like I'm not going to cry.
I'm getting pissed at you actually for thinking that you need fucked up people
for actors.
If you're going to have actors you want have real good ones,
those people better be fucked up.
Most of them.
This is a few of them that aren't fucked up at a really good actress,
but mostly few and far between.
Most of them are on mass.
Daniel Day Lewis is a bit,
and it's gotta be crazy.
He's so good.
He's got to be completely,
I live on a farm somewhere in Scotland or something,
man.
Think about how good that motherfucker is.
Remember that movie where he played a boxer?
The motherfucker became a boxer for like a year trained every day like a boxer.
You Watch that movie.
That is the best portrayal of a boxer in a movie where he looks,
he looks like a real boxer,
not some bullshit like Sylvester Stallone movie where it looks like he never
threw a punch and a man in a competition has life,
right to worry about being countered.
You know,
Daniel Day Lewis,
his hands up move in,
throwing faints.
He looks like a real goddamn box.
Broken nose and all that.
Genius is a genius actor.
He just comes out of the,
it comes out in the public like every four years,
perhaps an Oscar and comes back home.
Nuts.
The guys completely out of his mind,
but he's amazing.
He is fucking gangs in New York.
Remember that Jesus Christ was a Bob.
The builder put your heel,
the butcher or something and there will be blood.
He was absolutely [inaudible] fuck adding or who can do that?
Oh,
who can do that?
Like him?
Nobody and they'll only stays that way in his trailer,
you know?
Yeah.
There's a few guys.
It's a few of those guys.
Russell Crowe is fat as fuck now.
I haven't seen him in like,
oh my goodness here it can picture of him.
He went on a bike ride and he stopped and he's got his like bike outfit on a
stupid little helmet and he's smoking a cigarette and he is fat as fuck.
That's funny.
Like he's just gigantic fat.
I got a couple of years since I,
yes,
I had a picture.
I since all the fat when he did Robin Hood,
man,
he had a cut way to make Robin too.
You can't have a rotting Robin Hood as a fat guy,
but he's one of those can't hard drinking hard smoking act or dudes.
Yeah,
he's a wild man.
It's crazy.
Fucker.
That's why he's so good.
I watched a beautiful mind on the way to Australia out of respect,
because I was going to Australia anyway.
Yeah,
and it was on the plane.
It was one of those options.
Forgot.
I'll fucking go that move.
And that was 2000 best picture of 2001 I think.
Best Picture.
I don't know what it was.
Fucking gladiator.
One,
2000 and then that one,
one,
2001 he was cleaning up at that.
You know,
I watched the other day that I forgot how fucking good it was.
Contact.
Oh yeah.
I watched that recently on Netflix,
dude.
I put it on Twitter and all these people are going,
Whoa,
are you God took soaks texts.
All awesome.
You're gay.
You are gay bar.
The letter u.
The letter are gay.
Hello.
Hey,
contact socks.
No,
it's contacts.
Great.
I watched that recently.
I wrote that.
Yeah.
You know what?
You know,
what's that horrible movie,
but almost in that same idea,
it's again with uh,
Dennis Quaid and he's got the CB radio and he's talking to the past.
Oh,
know what you're talking about?
Yeah.
Chimko visal yes.
This is like one word.
Like Glen happened to that guy played fucking genius and he's gone and he's
gone.
That doesn't even make sense.
I mean,
that guy should have been gigantic door.
That movie was a huge movie,
was huge,
but it was one of those movies,
I think where the movie was huge or than who was in it.
And here's another issue.
The movie was very antisemitic,
very antisemitic.
I mean that was the argued,
you know,
whether or not that was historically accurate or I dunno what,
whatever the fuck it is.
You don't know you weren't there.
And the way it's depicted,
it's,
it's to picked it to me,
like the Jews will be huge problem,
which is,
I don't know if it's me.
Look,
the whole thing I think is fiction in the first place and I don't,
I just,
it seems to me the whole story is so convoluted.
And even if there was a man named Jesus,
who knows what the fuck really went down,
I can still get why people will buy that and then not buy other things.
It's like,
yeah,
no world's not getting warmer.
No wait,
no,
no global warming here.
But there's a story of this guy who came back from the dead.
It's like,
wait,
where are you?
Where are your priorities?
You know?
But Jim Caviezel playing him was really strange because you know,
he got really obsessed with it because he was 33 at the,
and [inaudible] is 33 name is JC.
Yeah.
And you know,
I mean,
how funny is it?
This movie is incredibly religious movie that made incredible amounts of money
was made by us psychopath and absolute [inaudible].
Now that you look at it in the past and you look at who he is now and the hear
those tapes where he's,
you should Josh blow man,
just insane.
Red Hide,
spit flying out of his fucking mouth.
I mean,
he's off the deep end.
Crazy.
And he made the most successful religious movie of all time.
Like bonded it himself.
Yeah.
And then had to turn that profit to incredible amounts of money because of it.
He never saw a passion of the Christ.
I did it.
I used to have a bit about it that it was a two hour movie about a dude with
magic who got his ass kicked and I go,
that is the last movie with subtitles I'll ever see without confluent.
It.
Wasn't that an Aramaic or something like I remember that.
Yeah.
People were coming out of theaters all moved and crying.
I don't,
yeah,
I don't know what the language was.
It might've been Aramaic.
I think that's what they spoke at the time.
Right.
What they spoken and they offered up the subtitles.
But if only want subtitles.
Yeah.
It's unlike you.
It's either comfort or some Swedish weird film where people are going to get
killed or some Japanese horror movie.
Green Goo,
you know,
I'll watch ring to ours.
Labyrinth.
Um,
people want to believe,
man.
They want to believe and they don't want you to take it away from them.
Netflix has just offered up,
for instance,
stream my favorite TV show of all time.
The twilight zone,
1959 and a bunch of shit.
And I thought about you because the very first episode is an episode called
where is everybody where the man is undergoing a sensory deprivation experiment
and losing his fucking mind while doing it.
And it's revealed at the end obviously that it's a military experiment,
but that's uh,
that show spoiler alert,
huge.
Uh,
it aired and 59,
I got a POB.
Right.
Bags.
I have something on a subject.
Okay,
cool.
Yeah.
At [inaudible] 59.
So I figured what the hell.
Yeah,
there's certain shows like that that I love watching.
One is that I had another thing,
it's just like old,
like Laura and Hardee's.
I love fucking Netflix that become addicted to it.
Netflix has made me this document documentary watching asphalt.
Like I'm and I'm,
and I'll watch one on like belly button lint.
I'll be like,
did you see that belly button there?
Have you noticed though?
Like,
like normal.
The other day I just realized that for cable TV,
I how much I spend per month for cable TV.
I Bet I would think 95% of the,
the,
the content that I watch,
his family guy,
I'll lay in bed,
turn on cartoon network.
Oh,
family guy watch it for three hours,
go to bed.
Right.
But it's like amazing.
Like how much I wish that we could get to a point of cable TV where we can Ella
cartoony all,
you know,
they say they'll never do that though because it's like,
but cable is offering now.
Like I saw it,
my mom said I had like on the man,
like you can get HBO premium.
Like one thing that Aaron Hbo,
but I don't want,
I don't turn my TV on hardly ever.
Yeah.
I mean hardly ever.
I watch everything on my computer and my phone in here,
you know what I mean?
And I get the updates.
Who's got the new documentaries coming on?
Netflix and all that stuff,
you know,
and I'll watch the most boring of crap too.
I don't care.
Source Code is a pretty fucking good movie man.
Source Code.
Jake Glen Allen Hall,
the new mode.
Pretty fucking good movie man.
Yeah,
it's about a god.
I don't want to tell you the whole story because I don't want to give it away,
but it's,
it's really interesting and it involves time travel.
It's pretty dope.
Moving handle,
visiting his time,
traveling.
Uh,
Donnie Darko.
He was,
uh,
it was also a time traveling.
Yeah.
No Shit.
Yeah,
yeah.
True.
Yeah.
It's a very well regarded one too.
Yeah,
it's a good one.
Yeah.
This is a,
this is very interesting.
I don't know if it's as good as Donnie Darko,
but I don't remember because I haven't seen done Darko and a long time,
you know,
movies like they become mythical.
Like Donnie Darko.
It's one of those moments.
So it was one of those movies was bad ass,
bad ass guy,
peers,
some of his,
the,
the seem a lot better because they were a long time and then he'd go back and
watch them and go,
that wasn't that good.
Or I was just young and dumb.
I remember Donnie Darko being weird.
It was weird but it does have,
it does hold up.
Have you ever seen primer?
That's the best time travel movie.
A great movie.
Yeah.
That one is it that you got to watch that one a few times.
Really independent movie.
Very small budget.
Considered like one of the best.
I mean you know you,
you talk back to the future.
That's you know,
for layman's purposes that works great.
They laid the rules for primer is one of those where they really adhere to the
rules and the time,
you know the fabric of time and how you can't do this and you can get sick and
all that.
She liked the things,
the nuances about actual time traveling that people have taken to study.
Here's what would happen to your body if you did that.
You know,
Tom was the most fascinating subject of all to me.
I don't know that I don't think of it.
I mean I think eventually it's going to be breached.
It has to be.
That's the end of time.
Human beings are going to figure out everything.
We figured out so much so far and we were not going to stop and as long as we
stay alive,
and they just found some,
they just found out that the Caldera volcano under Yellowstone is way bigger
than previously thought.
Oh really?
It's fucking giant Super Volcano.
It kills everybody and just found out it's even bigger.
Anyway,
if something like that doesn't happen,
people are going to continue to innovate.
They're going to continue to make a faster phone,
a faster computer,
uh,
a car that doesn't need to be recharged for a month.
It's going to be Internet through the air at ridiculous fiber optic speeds.
It's all going to eventually come to a up ahead.
He's gonna come to that rate.
Kurt's wheel singularity,
that Terence Mckenna TimeWave zero point of infinite novelty.
It's going to happen,
man.
It's,
it has to,
it's a thing where it's like you see more and more articles that talk about how
in theory,
I think it's,
I mean,
Einstein proved,
in theory it's absolutely possible,
but now they're really,
there's funding private funding,
but funding going towards actually taking this seriously.
If we're going to take all that seriously,
let's take this through to it.
It's just like the nuclear power issue.
They were there,
the nuclear power issue is something where they came up with something and they
figured out how to do it and then they just went ahead and do it without having
it completely worked out.
All right.
They went ahead and did it without having some,
you know,
agreed upon,
uh,
ability to shut it off without having some agreed upon ability to store all the
waste before we start producing it.
They just started doing it.
They just started doing it and then we're going to do that with everything.
But they did that with the space program,
all that.
They do that with everything they do that they're doing with the large Hadron
collider and they're,
they're out there and you know,
smashing atoms,
making a Higgs Boson particle and creating little miniature black holes.
They really are not exactly sure what's going to happen.
They're taking some chances and sometimes things go wrong and that's,
and things are going wrong in Japan right now and they're going to continue to
go wrong and as well as go right.
But no matter what things are gonna keep moving,
they moved past the nuclear bombs of the 1940s to what we're capable of today.
And that's going to be nothing compared to anti-matter weapons that are,
they're coming up with right now.
They're coming up with some shit right now.
Actual Reagan's that we're seeing the laser that they shot down,
they,
they did a demonstration recently where they,
um,
a boat was a mile away and they shot it with this laser and caused the,
the,
um,
uh,
engines to catch on fire from a mile away.
You know,
so they've got some crazy shit.
They're working on that.
That's nothing compared to,
I'm sure a bunch of their shit.
The drones,
the drones and the scariest thing,
man,
these fucking,
the,
their ability to operate these little tiny machines that looked like bugs,
you know,
they can,
they can get them little tiny ones and flying around and fucking make videos.
And people insurance that's,
have you seen there's even a thing for the iPhone now,
that little helicopter you can fly.
They've had their first,
uh,
a friendly fire incident with drones as well.
There was a thing today.
I retweeted it.
It's on my Twitter.
If you're interested.
There's a,
some drones kilts and fucking people really killed some US soldiers.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
It was a,
it was off the drudge report.
They're flying drones and Japan.
It's food right now,
aren't they?
To get a look inside the reactor.
I would assume they would do something like that.
It's pretty accurate now.
It's really scary shit man.
It is.
You know,
you retweeted.
I was even better than that though.
Kitty kissing a dolphin.
Oh,
that was the cutest thing.
I could watch that shit all day.
He's a cat and a dolphin being all snuggly with each other.
That was the cutest thing ever,
man.
I wonder if that's like one of the first times a dolphin has played with the
cat.
The cat was a bad motherfucker.
He didn't care.
He's like hanging out over the water and he's not even trippin Cath can't on
swim.
They would freak out if they fell in that instant death.
Meanwhile,
he's like,
you know,
dancing on the edge.
It doesn't care.
It's me can swatted the dolphin.
I haven't seen that.
It's truly an os.
Very cute.
Especially for a guy like Brian Price who loves them.
He loves his little kitties.
Kitties.
You have that one of the switch fee.
Had too many kitties.
I have to get on a dog and I'm so sick of it.
Oh,
I retweeted this.
Um,
the,
uh,
Asu adult film star did not get,
she did not go to,
she did not get kicked out.
She didn't get suspended.
No.
I mean,
I was going to say that they're pretty lenient.
Campus did not get her scholarship revoked.
It's not like,
that's not,
you know,
yeah.
Party school central there.
Yeah.
The A,
apparently it was a,
the whole thing is scripted.
She says,
I knew going in there,
it was for sex.
She said she was paid $2,000 and insured the video would only appear on the part
of the website people had to pay to see.
That didn't happen.
The video found its way on to free porn sites like pores.
Well,
she has no cases or anything.
Of course.
Welcome to the Internet.
Hey,
let me teach you about,
yeah,
the Internet's this perpetual adequate.
It's there forever.
So I guess they just can let you eat.
There's the school says go do some porn.
Do you still have your scholarship?
I mean half the people in score and Bray Asu.
It's amazing how porn is acceptable.
As long as it's an accident.
You know,
like Kim Kardashian of Kim Kardashians got hired by vivid and got gang fuck by
50 football players,
shot loads in their mouth,
then she'd be done.
Nobody would want to have anything to do with her.
But the fact that it was like her man and she was fucking him.
And meanwhile,
why is there so many cameras?
What's going on here?
There's cameras are from weird angles,
I guess people in the room with you.
Okay.
What the fuck is going on,
man?
I just cuts one shots,
two shots.
What kind of a video is this?
You know,
and what is it?
what the fuck was that like,
but that somehow or another is acceptable.
It's the most ridiculous hoax over.
It's fortuitous for them.
It's a career builder.
I mean she's who she is because of that takes these gigantic dude,
she's gigantic.
She's bigger than all of us.
Pretty much everyone we know clocks.
Geez.
That pitches on billboards in Australia almost that she was on cosmos.
The cover of a Turkey version yesterday.
There was a big uproar because Turkey put her on the cover of the Turkish
version of Cosmo,
you know,
tourniquets,
Turks and Armenians,
that little bad blood there.
Oh really?
And she's an Armenian and she's an Armenian.
And,
uh,
she's,
she's gracing the cover of a Turkish publication,
not by her choice.
Cosmo went and did it without her.
Uh,
but it was funny,
a bunch of our videos got pissed cause Koby Bryant did a spot for Turkish
Airlines.
It's like he's gotten a horse in that race.
You know what I mean?
That I understand he should do that.
But her,
it's like,
yeah,
that's a little weird.
That's a little weird.
It's a little weird.
Like Morty Solomon wearing a swastika.
Almost what w the way society is set up right now with like these teen moms
shows and the real housewives of Beverly Hills and Kim Kardashians.
It's almost like the scene in the running man when they have those ridiculous
shows.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean it is so you're so right.
It's almost like it's getting to this weird sort of surreal point where it's
like,
wow,
this is what everyone's fixated on.
The fascinated by 16 year olds and get knocked up,
have a TV show now and you see them scream at their boyfriend can't up you
fucking lazy fat piece of Shit and the hell out of weeping and everything's
beeping.
And the guy gets in the car and he's taken the baby and the girls screaming in
his face,
big Duke and what the fuck are we watching?
And You wonder why people who have lost their psychic abilities and all that
shit.
I used to think that when I was doing fear factor,
when I was doing fear factor,
I was like,
we are three seasons away from the running man.
We're like right here,
we're right here.
Well the door,
they'll come,
they'll line up.
We were doing fear factor and you know,
everybody's like,
well you know the shows like that man are designed by the government to keep you
soft and no,
no,
they're not.
They're made by people because that's what people want to see.
But the,
even the people making them,
it's not like they're the grand programmers of the universe and they've done
this on purpose to try to lower people's standards.
No,
this is what you want to see,
man.
You really do want to say some dumb shit.
It's a reflection of society.
That's what they want.
It's,
it's a fascinating thing to be a part of too.
Cause when we were doing fear factor,
while we're doing it,
we were all going,
I think really letting us do this.
Like it was,
you know,
we'd say,
okay,
we uh,
we said we're going to blend rats.
What did they,
what did they say?
They said,
good,
we've got a green light.
They got greenlight unblending rats.
Fuck.
What about drink your own piss?
Nope.
We just got a red light.
Can't drink your own pets weed.
Every now and then we'll get red lights,
you know?
Okay.
How about eat a Buffalo Dick?
I remember that.
Greenlight greenlight.
Buffalo Dicks.
We can eat buffalo.
Dick's.
Holy Shit.
That's funny.
We tell them it's buffalo dicks.
Yes.
You're allowed to tell him.
How about balls?
Yes,
you can eat balls.
Remember we'd have boiled balls.
Oh,
giant bull testicles with the skin on them.
All the veins around it.
Like did you ever get sick watching them do that stuff?
Oh,
a bunch of times.
I never threw up on the set.
I only threw up at home once.
I would,
funny enough,
I would watch that show with my nose plugs thinking like just reflects literally
watch like this.
Cause I feel like I catch a whiff of something,
you know,
it wasn't the most fun thing to do,
because it was really fun sometimes,
but other times it was fucking tedious as hell.
But looking back on it and like,
wow,
I was a part of some weird part of fucking television history.
One of the most,
you're now shows ever.
There's nothing before after that's like it.
Oh,
sorry.
It was so strange to be a part of it.
I was at the 99 cent store the other day and they're still sewing like fear
factor candy.
Like that's got to show around the world still,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I get emails from people sometimes in other countries we're just started
showing.
Yeah,
for real.
It just started.
Just started there.
You know they're cooked.
She says,
got it.
I know it.
That's another,
there's countries here just now getting like the,
I guess apparently my sister's boyfriend is from Germany.
He was saying like,
you know,
they showed nightrider rider,
like now they're like,
because they,
David Hasselhoff,
David Hasselhoff and they pried him,
but they'll countries will get stuff that we are done with that wrapped in the
90s that wrapped in the 80s but they'll think it's new as interests accordingly.
Is it going weird when a comic goes to another country and becomes big in that
country?
Oh yeah.
That's weird.
That is right when they did.
They're not big in America,
but they go someone that become big.
Yeah.
That's really strange.
Right.
That's real weird.
Especially if it's a,
if your native country,
you can't seem to find,
I mean it's different with musicians.
Hendricks did it,
you know.
Right.
A few other guys,
but they came to America and America's always been at the top of the ice cream
pile.
And that's where the cherry is.
There's still holes.
Yeah.
I mean it's still,
that's the grand,
you know,
the,
the big stage supposedly.
Right.
But for like a lot of comics,
like going to other countries,
you become more successful.
You know,
like arch barker is gigantic in Australia to see,
oh my God dude.
He's like,
he's like Richard Pryor in Australia.
No bullshit man.
He's fucking huge.
What happened while,
I guess he went over there and kicked ass,
want to know a bunch of tours,
did a bunch of tours over there and they just love him.
He lives there now apparently he like,
you know you've got a house there and he's like fuck it comes on tour in
America.
But most of the time he spends in Australia sells out like you know,
fucking 2030 nights in a row at places.
I was wondering what happened to,
cause it's like around the time like him to meet you.
Martin started getting a lot of attention.
That seems like one kind of went the other way.
Well you went to Australia and just started kicking ass for him.
He said he's like the biggest comic in,
in Australia I think.
Pablo giant,
well worldwide doesn't,
he does huge and like Finland,
he's got some,
some pockets of fans out there.
He sounds silly to you don't really have to be adept at the language to
understand Pablo.
Well that's the thing.
It's the language barrier would I think certainly it has to keep me in English
speaking only nations obviously and even the most,
you know,
Americanized ones because it's like,
well a lot of Europe speaks English as well.
If they come to your show.
I've done shows in Ireland,
I've done shows,
you know,
I've done chosen uh,
a bunch of different,
I never did Germany,
but I've done them all throughout the UK.
And you get people that speak a gang of different languages and English,
French,
English,
they speak at all.
They,
it just seems to me like I watched a documentary with Eddie Izzard learned
French to do a set and France.
Whoa,
that was pretty cool.
And connected with them.
Not as much as he would want to,
but he learned French are now growing up a Brit,
he probably knew his fair share is it was good.
Eddie Izzard's a bad motherfucker.
I used to think he's a silly man with a dress on like when I first saw him.
What cross dressing.
What are the,
what is it?
What kind of weird gimmick is that?
Then I saw him do this one show where he went on a marathon every day for like
30 fucking days or something crazy like that.
It might've been even more than 30 days.
Something nuts,
man.
This guy ran all the way around the UK.
Oh Wow.
Dude.
It was ridiculous.
And they filmed him.
They followed him around with cameras.
I mean,
he got hurt,
man.
His feet were fucked up and he kept Ron and his legs would not up.
He could barely move.
He could barely shuffle forward.
What was he kept going?
I forget some sort of charity thing.
I watched a documentary on him and they talked about the address,
the cross dressing issue,
but by the time you get done with the film,
he's so fascinating.
That's just a little side thing to the point where you don't even think of it
anymore.
You know what I mean?
He's a,
he's a bad motherfucker.
It's really interesting too.
It's a cross dressing thing where it's like,
like guy who smoked cigarettes.
It's like I kind of need to do it.
Know that's what he's literally
like,
I need,
I have to do it.
It's not like I'm not into dudes,
nothing like that.
I just really need to do this once a day.
And I was just like,
wow,
I can,
that's what he would do when he would go on stage.
Like he was really like that was,
he was into crossdresser.
He's just into cross dressing.
There's no,
it wasn't a gimmick.
It's not a gimmick.
There is no sexual thing.
It was just some yes,
no sensual thing.
I mean it's probably,
he says,
he always says right people I know he likes what he did.
He was so interesting.
He made you forget that he dressed like that.
Yeah.
He's a bad motherfucker when anybody can run a marathon every day as many days
as he did.
It was a,
it was a ridiculous documentary.
I don't know why it didn't air in America cause NBC or someone should have
picked it up cause it was really compelling.
But it's interesting.
They should have eroded simultaneously.
It was a really compelling,
I mean if they had room for it anywhere it would have done very well because it
was a really gripping,
I started it not thinking I was going to get into it at all,
so it gives a fuck about some idiot running everywhere,
you know?
I'm like,
this is stupid,
you know,
run everywhere.
But then I realized like how much he's pushing through this and doing it in
great spirits and laughing and,
and these guys got a solid personality.
There's a documentary,
she'll watch it.
I watched one recently called still bill.
Have you heard of this one?
No.
It's a story of Bill withers.
He's a,
he's a soul singer,
kind of RNB guy from the 70 [inaudible] sang and wrote lean on me.
Ain't no sunshine when she's gone to him.
But this guy didn't pick up a guitar or sing or learn to do any of it until he
was 32 years old.
Holy Shit.
You want to talk about natural ability?
This guy picks it up when he's 32 rights.
Lean on me.
Below is up.
Leaves the music business like 10 years after being in it sometime around the
late seventies just had enough and just collects his royalties and mind you,
it makes a ton of money.
He's the nicest,
most decent person you ever saw.
He's from a slab fork.
West Virginia has this real country way of living but lives up in the Hollywood
hills.
But you talk to this guy,
he's the most lovable guy in the world.
Like I say,
it doesn't have to do anything.
He smoked,
but you know the whole thing is he's,
people have been begging him to come do tracks,
come back into the music industry for years and at the end,
I won't tell you what happened.
Somebody begged him to come back and it's just like,
it just shows this guy who is a Chris Brown.
No,
it's nothing like that.
Thank God I would've,
I would've never had said that.
I hate that guy.
I feel bad for him.
Who is that?
Chris Brown.
Yeah.
I feel bad for him being him.
Yeah,
that's,
he hates being him.
You can,
it's a hard person to being,
man.
He's a mess.
You can tell that guy has no,
you can see it in his,
came back and wrote a song and it was horrible.
I can't tell you that.
You got to watch it still bill.
But it still bill still bill.
One of the best documentaries I've seen in a per Bobby Lee's recommendation.
Funny enough.
Wow.
And not funny enough because sometimes he recommends really good stuff,
but other times he recommends horrible.
It's the worst thing he's ever recommended.
Uh,
the,
the um,
what you call it,
movie with a River Phoenix.
His brother.
Uh Oh yeah,
I heard that was terrible.
It was awful.
He thought it was brilliant.
It's fucking brilliant.
Fucking brilliant.
It's brilliant.
It wasn't brilliant.
A lot of his stuff he bought forgot.
Did you impressions Bobby's in the good,
pretty good movies.
And you do Bobby Lee.
Can you do,
I can do fucking Bobby Lee.
That's,
he is been a fucking bomb.
Joe Rogan.
I'm gonna fucking bomb.
And they walked down pretty close.
Yeah.
Close as much as he can.
Jesse Ventura,
Jesse,
the body been Torah.
That's now it's Jessie the mine.
Ventura.
That's,
come on Joe.
Rogan's podcast to talk dot truth.
Yeah,
I think that's pretty good.
Damn good.
I've never done that before.
I'm nine.
One one was an inside job.
If you think the latter,
you're the one who's missing four brother.
You don't think that Rumsfeld knew what we was doing when he told those troops
to stand down?
Niche almost sounds a little Sam Elliott in there too.
That a little bit.
Raj Rail.
You don't get any roadhouse quotes in.
You show that man to the door and if he doesn't go quietly,
what does it use this drug and head and buy yourself a dodge ram pickup with all
the torque and you definitely know how to stretch his words out.
The waist turns his words and rocky get on the bike.
Rocky.
Dennis,
what was that thing you did about ice,
tea and cocoa?
What did you do recently?
Oh,
uh,
what w police show St Tripoli show.
Uh,
maybe ball baby pool.
Yeah,
we did a ice t commercial with,
with a coco.
A great cocoa look alike.
My Maya,
did she look just like,
oh,
go for it.
She was built like her.
She was an anomaly,
like this huge ass,
huge boobs and there's tiny waist.
Now granted it was all sculpted that way,
but it was still this anomaly.
It was like,
whoa.
It was ridiculous.
Sculptor meaning like operations,
operations at top.
I've heard people seen that Coco and my wife said she's absolutely beautiful.
I um,
but uh,
yeah,
we did the ice tea thing.
We did the baby bull man.
That went over pretty well and he saw a red band tweeted it and ice tea tweeted
back.
What did he,
what did he say?
I said a,
uh,
I made a video.
What do you think about this?
And he'd say,
it's interesting.
I say it's interesting.
Yeah,
that's pretty God damn good ice tea.
That's that I that man that's dead.
That's 100%.
And I'm fighting off a cold from the past three days.
Sometimes I want to have a cold.
My impressions to get a little better.
Like I've never done that Ventura one before.
I didn't know if you could do it.
You do a good bro call.
I left on good.
Oh Amy,
I'm heartbroken.
Sugars,
bombs are falling and draw all of I
did.
You know Tom Brokaw was a pothead 24 hour a day.
Paul is he really prideful pot?
Perry.
I take pong reps on a daily
daily smoking indycar sativa makes me not want to do my God.
That's hilarious.
That's so good guy nuts.
He really does smoke pot.
Where'd you hear this?
You know,
I read it somewhere and I just ran with it.
I didn't research it.
Just yeah.
Say Tom.
Uh,
Tom.
Tom Parker.
How do you spell bro?
Call Br.
Okay.
That's boy.
Ocean saw a family guy last night where there was a gang of Bro.
Cause there's like 12 of them.
No,
I never did it.
Not Interested.
Where did,
he was like experimented with a little marijuana.
I never liked a lot of other people.
You just made up some shit.
Somebody made it up and I wanted to believe it.
Okay.
We'll give you too.
I wish I didn't Google it.
Alright.
Who else,
who's confirming says is there,
is there some clearinghouse of,
of whether a celebrity is a pothead or not and broke off Alfie 10 posts.
If it's a topic and working on a John Lithgow as well.
My girlfriend doesn't like it,
but I do actually.
She does like it.
Hello decks to move women.
Can you do Nancy Grace?
She's my favorite.
Nancy grace.
This is a real problem.
Yeah.
La uh,
babies in Florida.
We are alive right now.
Who?
Me?
Yeah.
Oh,
there was a good march.
Was that all the other one that you do?
That's amazing.
Is Morgan Freeman,
isn't it?
It Morgan Freon.
That's ridiculous.
I need to fray Andy to frighten.
Gave me hand jobs those last few nights.
Talking about your penis,
Morgan.
My penis hangs down to my knee caps and I'm wearing knickerbockers shorts.
You can tell
show why not do lean on me.
Quotes what you get in that.
Lock us on Bob Future.
All right now.
And then I take quotes from,
from lean on me and I changed them around like,
and lean on me.
There's this kid he keeps asking cause this kids like,
Yo,
Mr Clock,
man,
I'm going to move away man.
I'm gonna go make money.
He's like,
you'll be dead in a year.
So he's like,
no,
no man,
I'm going to go work for my uncle.
But you dead in the year to be in a,
a buddy would take it and be like,
Yo Mr. Clark,
I got accepted to Harvard man,
you'll be dead in a yes on not going to Harvard in Cambridge.
He'll be dead in a yes.
Well fuck you.
Then Clark Joe did a ice cube thing the other day and we were in the green room
baked as hell and we saw this commercial for a Sitcom for ice cubes.
New sitcoms.
Are we there yet?
Really?
Damn.
Why you kids make all this noise?
I pick up little Chris and put them on the porch.
Are Ours cubes terrible.
It's hard.
That's telling.
You know I saw him in concert reason kids.
Oh I'm in concert kappa rule about me.
The ticket we went to go see him and he didn't do anything off death
certificate.
The album I grew up loving that I haven't changed my why not allowed to.
What did he do fresh out of school?
Cause I was a high school Grad so there's a little askew.
I got it there.
What did he do?
Uh,
stuff from post 98 I hadn't listened to anything ice cube since 95 so it was one
of the new shit.
I guess he still makes new shit and then he brought his son out like I want to
hear it.
His son and her trials and tribulations though.
His son,
he has two sons.
One looks just like him from 1987 really the thing is it's like,
that's the thing with second generation hip hop dude.
You'd better come seriously correct.
Cause hip hop's born in poverty and thrives and struggle and second generation
of hip hop.
I don't mind a rich rapper who became rich on his own,
but the second generation thing,
you know,
it's hard.
Harvard Westlake a lot,
da homie.
You know it doesn't,
it was,
yeah,
I'm sure he still had to grow up having ice cube as a father,
which fucked all right.
Ice Cube.
I'll tell you this.
At the age of 17 moved to Arizona and went to a trade school and studied
architecture before founding Nwa.
Check on that.
O'Shea Jackson,
his name is.
Wow.
So how w what does this kid,
this kid goes up and wrap comes up and perhaps about hard times.
Joe Rogan,
I heard he's hard.
Tom Or Tom's?
Joe Rogan.
I heard it was good though.
I heard he was,
he was good.
He's got that booming voice like ice cube has.
What does he say about the hard times?
I don't even remember.
I just wanted to leave so bad.
By the time it was over,
it was at the House of Blues.
You not the last time I was at the House of Blues.
I saw you there and you ran into me cause we went to chewy show.
Why we did that.
I don't know was what it was.
2001 two maybe something like that.
And then when you've gotten the chewy good dude too good.
I'm going to the house of blues,
Bro.
You've got to come today.
He's a crazy guy.
And as a bouncer,
he wasn't your favorite guy,
but as a band member and that was pretty good.
He was good man.
It was weird.
It was like chewy was the doorman at the comedy store.
Like fucking forever.
Yeah.
But he was a nice guy.
I mean he was,
he had a like you to be a nice guy.
He liked I me luckily.
Thank God I've seen what,
he didn't listen like you became a real problem and he always liked me and uh,
he,
I even introduced him one time.
I introduced him one time at the house blows.
Oh yeah.
They're fucking good man.
He's real good.
Chewy Castro.
And what was the band called?
Shui and the uh,
I don't know.
I remember the song.
Hey chewy.
It was,
well,
yeah.
Hey,
Julie is going to play with me Bro.
Yeah,
I remember that rejects just to come jam with them.
Vick changes to go on stage with Chile.
Really?
And this was back before Rick James was like immortalized by Dave Chappelle.
Yeah.
This was 2000 2001 yeah.
Rick James was like,
you know,
people like didn't care that much that he was there after the Dave Chappelle
sketches.
If you went on stage,
they would have gone Corey.
Right.
But this was,
I mean,
obviously it was dead,
you know,
but this was a 2001 or so.
He would go on dude,
Chili's bad.
It was real weird to know someone from work and then you know,
they say,
hey,
we come see my band.
I'm like,
Oh God,
here we go.
Here we go.
But you know,
I mean you didn't really expect your much astro and like the notes,
the notes get what the fuck they were.
Yes.
Somebody can find that.
True cast is also the bad guy in James Bond,
right?
Sure.
He Castro don't dressed up like that guy.
Cut your head off that he's dressed like that.
Or like somebody from a clockwork orange or somebody who works at her money with
his hat.
Remember we would like hit sculptures and shit and knock arms off.
It's fucking stupid hat of it.
Sure,
we can do that.
Well,
Cheerios,
they had a side job there.
I forgot what it was.
Great.
Lowbrow shape.
How many interesting people have you met out of the Goddamn comedy store that is
like a,
uh,
a whirlpool.
It's sucks.
All the Weirdos right to it.
It's the overlook hotel from the shining man.
It's just,
it is.
It's a vortex for the Weirdos.
And have you ever met Mickey Biggie?
Ah,
it's a guy who's literally so funny to watch because he's so crazy,
but he's the most like,
it's funny to watch somebody interact with them like a customer Khan.
He's not,
he's just some dude who hangs out there,
but they're like,
it's their bathrooms here.
He'd be like,
ah,
like the most difficult person you could ever run into if you just want basic
information as a new guy.
No,
he's been there since they got the tinted glasses.
Glasses,
mustache.
He's 77.
He's been hanging out apparently is a trust fund guy.
He's a mystery don guys.
And He,
I think he wasn't deemed on guy for a little while,
but tried to avoid that.
Um,
John Barris freaked me out with all those people had been rough.
There was some amazing characters in that stuff though,
that,
that Mickey's one of them is there no greater master of nuts.
Then dawn does ringleader.
We just had one death squad,
man.
He was talking about the old days when a comedy store was in a basement of a
restaurant.
Oh,
that was the Westwood version.
Yeah,
that was the word Kennison used to rock out.
Yeah.
He's talking about Kennison and how there was a bullet hole.
I didn't know this and the belly room and the sign of the bill that he pulled
out.
I think it was about him and dice being mad at each other.
Wow.
Kinison pulled out a gun and shot a fucking side.
That's craziness.
It was pretty interesting.
Podcasts.
Yeah,
that's a,
you know who else has a great ruler over the craziest as Ricky room?
He always has.
They always worship him.
It's so funny like how he's got that power of the crazy or they are,
the more they confide in him,
which is so funny cause he's the most cynical mother fucker on her.
You know what I mean?
He just makes fun of him right to their face.
They're like,
oh,
I love you Rick.
You're always good.
To me.
It's like now that we're know weird people in Hollywood trying to be seen,
trying to be her,
trying to be found.
Find me.
What a weird,
creepy place to live.
Let's do you ever think you'd ever moving out of here?
Are you going to stay here forever?
If I did,
I moved to New York.
Basically.
I could live in New York.
I can live in la,
but I want like to have a uh,
somewhere in Montana and I want to go fly fishing and just be left the hell
alone.
That's what I'm talking about.
Dogs.
I go,
let's go.
Often we keep saying this man,
let's go fish.
It's a spring.
Let's go fishing.
We should've done,
we were in Portland.
We should have stayed an extra day and went salmon fishing on Catalina island.
Is their fishing there.
It's ocean.
Now.
Watch the urban fishermen.
This guy will show you where to fish and your city,
dude,
I'm a huge fan.
I saw that show.
What is,
what is that on fishermen?
This guy.
He's the one that hunting shows.
Uh,
it's hunting.
Fishing.
No,
it's actually like on travel,
I think.
And it's,
that guy's a,
I can la Ross or somebody,
I can Ellie or something.
His last name is,
and he,
she does urban fishing.
He'll catch fish in the Hudson river.
You'll catch fish,
you know?
No,
he doesn't eat him.
He's a sport fisherman.
So he tosses them all back.
But he'll show you,
if you live in a big city,
you can still find great fishing.
I fished three times a month,
you know,
it'd be cool.
Yeah.
When you guys go to Arizona a lot.
I go fly fishing.
I go bass fishing.
Me and my buddy Scotty g two the past fishing at Dobson ranch park.
Dude,
just throw him all day.
I caught a catfish at night waiting for my breaks to be done.
I was like,
I'm gonna go next door.
Catch a catfish.
Come back.
Did I got an emergency pole?
And there was this,
this was in Arizona.
In Arizona,
but not out here.
You know,
I catch,
I've got to do it out here too.
Where do you go fishing at the Santa Monica pier and fish without a license.
You can pitch it anywhere.
Yeah.
And the ocean.
You can fish it.
Our license without a license on the Santa Monica Pier.
You can fish.
Yeah.
How come?
Um,
I think it's kind of no man's land.
They can't really govern it.
You don't really need it.
I don't think you need a license to Ohsu Ocean fish at all.
Yeah,
I think you don't,
I think it's fresh water that you need all this fresh water and it's all like,
it's all that urban stuff.
You have to get that local urban license and then you have to get the lake
license.
But uh,
I,
I fish any chance I get,
it's so much like comedy,
it's just,
it's a patience game.
It's fun winning.
You get good at it.
You
get,
I'm not good at it.
I just do it a lot.
But I'm getting better.
I used to fish all the time when I was living in Jamaica Plain.
I used to go to Jamaica pawn and catch big ass fucking rainbow trout.
Yeah.
We catch a lot of fish there,
man.
And there was a lake there.
Massachusetts is great because there was a lot of different places to fish when
I was a kid.
But uh,
there was a lake near my house in Newton.
I caught a three pound bass and it's at a tiny ass pond,
so big ass fucking dominating shit.
And this pond,
I think swimming and fishing with sounds so good together.
Just hanging out.
I'd get knocked out by my own bay and I use Louis.
I'd have a top water hook.
I'd be afraid of it,
you know what I mean?
And I've gotten into Lewis now,
like as a kid I was always live bait,
but now I'm in the Lewis,
the sport,
the art of fishing and I got into fly fishing recently.
That some cool shit,
dude.
I used to low good at catching.
Oh awesome.
I used to love catching bass on floating rapalas cast him out.
Then just twitch it a little bit like a,
like a little fish that's fucked up ass her like torpedoes and no matter how
old,
that fucking thing,
like they couldn't,
they couldn't not hit it.
Did you want to catch bass?
Two spoons?
That's the best way,
spoons or silver things,
they'll click dying minnows against the stream.
That was the coolest thing about fishing when I was a kid.
You never knew what the fuck they wanted that day.
One day it was plastic worms.
The next day was spinner baits and there's all different things to catch him
with or they're smarter and wiser to some of you,
be efficient with somebody,
like what did he use?
And he caught something and you'd lose all confidence in what you had on that
damn.
And I need to get one of those.
We go to this place.
Uh,
my buddy,
one of the places I go with,
my mom lives next door to a lake.
Uh,
just one of these community likes.
I go fish,
tear polecat fish out of there.
I go to my buddy Scott McWilliam lives in tops and rant.
It's like four feet deep.
This water,
we take his dad's pontoon smoke balls and fucking fit the whole time.
Like just smoking bowls.
Fish sounds fun in the sun too.
It's,
it's the best time,
man.
I like fishing is has given me in my thirties this whole new,
it exercises the patients like I've got a lot more patients now.
There's something more visceral about hooking a big fish too,
man.
You know,
it's like there's something,
it just goes,
it charges up some caveman instinction.
You know,
you,
you won that day,
you know,
you won that day.
And I,
I've been places where it's like,
you know,
there's big whales swimming by,
they're not by nothing.
But then there's other nights where it's like,
you know,
you,
I was at my mom's house one night.
I said,
I'm going to catch a fucking fish right now,
and I'm taking hot dog with me.
That's how pathetic this is.
But they know the cat first.
They're fucking lake roaches.
They'll eat anything.
Throw the con chum the water with a little corn.
Sure enough,
two seconds later I had a bite on that hot dog.
I used to use a chicken liver,
used to buy chicken over a store near my grandfathers,
used to take me in Newark,
New Jersey,
which is going to take me to some fucking lake and we'd go fishing like late at
night.
It was so shifty back then too.
It was like so dangerous.
I'm hearing my old grandfather and it's late at night because that's when we
would catch the catfish.
So he took me to some creepy ass neighborhood late at night to catch fish
casting out liver into this lake.
I am pulled a 10 pound channel catfish.
Oh Wow.
All Brown and like a mud cats is crazy man.
I do that.
I go fishing anywhere.
I think you might be able to go to echo park.
I don't know if anybody's pull anything out of there.
I never eat that little pond over here in Calabasas down.
You know,
it's like in the middle.
I know what you're talking about.
Toluca lake.
I think there's nothing in there.
There's another place.
Uh,
there's um,
a lake,
a shit.
Forgot the name of it.
Lake Arrowhead.
No,
that's the place.
Lake Arrowhead is a big bear,
right?
Yeah,
that's a,
that's what,
that's one of the big ones.
Like are you talking to those places?
Like imagine living like right there,
like right on the lake.
I get big bear lake arrowhead as the fishing.
Like I don't go and get upset if I don't catch like it's being out there.
It's the smell.
It's the stillness.
I want to go canoeing.
Have you guys ever used to go canoeing?
Canoeing seems ridiculous.
Fun Man.
Going into a little lake.
Yes.
Whitewater rafting.
Whitewater go fishing out of a canoe,
but I usually just wade.
I like where they drop you off in the car and you go for like,
I don't know,
like three hours and then there's a pickup point near the end journey.
Did you go uh,
Ohio?
It's all over you.
There's like Kevin Bacon and Whitewater summer.
Yeah,
but it used to be so fine.
It wasn't Whitewater rafting,
but there was parts where it was like,
oh,
here's some rapids.
The whole thing on the buying a shitload a beer and drinking.
We should go out on a boat in a lake is the ship.
I got Shilhan relaxing,
floating on that boat to find nature by being out there in the first place.
I do ocean fishing once a year with my dad and we'll go off in Sonata and we'll
do a day trip.
And that's fun cause that's hardcore sport fishing.
You're pulling out Marlin tuna,
you know,
you name it macro 50 pounds like you're worn out by the end of the day.
But lately I've gone back to the freshwater fishing of just chilling out there,
making some dogs.
I get really nasty when people come to try to talk to who they played back off.
I'm out here alone,
you know?
Yes.
I am serious.
Upbeat it bro.
I didn't come from,
it is annoying when someone wants stop talking.
I don't mind that.
The common fishing questions,
hey,
how the and what are you using?
Then beat it but not like don't drop a chair bro.
I left the city to get away from you.
Some people would just sit in and talk to you.
Yeah,
my girlfriend,
she's all mad at me wrong.
I hope you have face age.
Let me fish in.
The ocean.
Vision is pretty dope,
but there's something about like still water,
like when you,
especially with a top Waterloo are or a fly,
he cast a flung and still watering.
Just give it a little twitch and that the trout comes up and blast it and you're
like,
Oh yeah,
I love that Shit.
We should go man.
Let's go fishing.
Let's do it.
I've been wanting to go hunting for a long time and I'd set it on my message
board.
All these fucking heavy Egan,
fucking Weirdo Hippie dudes wigged out.
You ever get to one thing you would if you had to eat fat?
Eat.
Yeah,
but I don't want to go.
If you were living on a ranch and there was some fucker,
don't be a Dick Hunter hot.
Dress it and use every possible.
I'll do the bird shit.
Hunting ducks and shit.
Fuck that.
But I used to hunt as a kid.
I used to shoot.
Thanks.
I just got sick of it.
I saw a rabbit out in your front yard.
My mind was like,
where's my red Ryder baby last him,
but I was letting you eat them.
How good is rabbit a pretty Gamey,
pretty lean,
you know,
uh,
if you've figured it's like venison when you eat that kind of stuff and he kind
of fast moving animal is always going to be very tough if you make a stew or
something like that,
three or four days and then ended up making like a stew three or four days.
Really when you sit in there and just throw the bunny in the crock pot field,
dress it,
throw it right in there in the fridge and let it sit in that stuff.
It was Jack Rabbit,
same subject came up yesterday when I was on the Adam Carolla show.
We were talking about,
you know,
cooking your own food and hunting and gathering your own food and how some
people are so opposed to it even though they eat meat.
We were so weird as human beings when this weird stage of,
you know,
getting past,
being an animal and all this shit that's connected to be an animal,
like you know,
killing food and you know,
and it causing suffering in order so that you survive.
We're so separated ourselves from all that shit.
It's like we've become some weird thing outside of nature connects to nature.
We have like agents that do the nature thing for us.
That's true.
You know,
it's very strange now these documentaries on exposing how your meat is made.
I've watched everybody and it's just like,
wow,
okay,
but I still got to eat meat because I get it,
but I won't eat that kind of meat.
Like now I get the whole purpose of going to a ranch and buying fresh farm shit.
Hey taco bell the other day and I knew that that study that it's not even meet,
but I still ate it.
What does it,
what does it fillers?
They said it's full as glass cardboard or something.
You know,
the thing is,
it's like I don't eat the fast food,
but it's like I would like,
I would be a hunter if I lived out on in Montana and I would feel dressed it and
use every part the right way,
like a real hunter does.
I have nothing against that.
Right.
You know what I mean?
I'm not doing drive bys on fucking deer and just leaving them out there.
But the thing is use it,
right.
I'm all for it.
You really do have to kill them and people need to wrap their heads around that
because otherwise you're going to have a massive amount of predators and
starvation hunting keeps the population go to West Virginia.
Go to these places where they're like,
fuck deer,
buck deer.
You know,
wait for hunting season to come.
Well,
in Colorado,
man,
you,
you have to,
you have to be careful everywhere you drive.
Especially when a in boulder,
because in boulder don't,
no one shoots him and they're in the mountains.
No.
So you know,
you're in a town,
so no one's shooting these deer.
So they're fucking everywhere.
And everywhere you go,
you've got to make sure some asshole dear doesn't jump out in front of the road
and slam into your car.
You ever been to Alaska?
Had that happen with the Moose there?
Oh,
praise God.
That's what moves everywhere.
And it's like,
sure enough,
one was standing in the road when we're leaving to go to the airport at
dangerous.
Well,
the Danes,
they're not,
they won't attack you,
but they're so tall that their knees or at your basically top of your car,
so when you hit them,
you're going to bring this,
you know,
2000 pounds is going to come rushing in,
right near windshield.
They're perfectly set up to come in and kill you.
And that's what happens is they come in and just,
you hit them and they fall into the cab of your call and you just get crushed.
Enormous man.
It's like before falling on you.
Yeah.
They're massive animals.
I mean,
they're,
they're territorial.
They'll come after you if they have to,
but they're like deer.
A deer will fuck you up if it has to,
but nine times out of 10 it will just bail.
Yeah.
Do they have like special bumpers that they put on trucks and shit out there to
make sure that they actually act those elk?
Same ideas like a deer guard but raised up,
you know like the tea guards on the back of a semi,
I think.
Same idea,
but on the top of your thing,
they have deer guards.
They do a lot of deer guards.
A lot of people have duty Alaska.
Have you been there?
No.
That was a fascinating man.
It was just very fascinated comedy there.
Sometime I would love to,
but Doug,
Stan hope decided that the people are too stupid.
They're,
oh really?
Yeah.
That's all he needed to know.
If Doug,
Doug will do any goddamn crowd,
Doug,
Doug will pull up into a bar.
There's not a s a chair to be found in a half a mile radius.
Everyone's standing piss drunk and Doug,
Doug,
we'll be up there.
You know,
no one wants to fuck your kid on my space.
I literally going through his act and he's got no problem and he stopped going
to Alaska.
I don't know what the exact details were,
but I used to go there and party all the time.
Enough per Luca Palanca and wheels Parisi.
We're doing that Gig.
Oh my goodness.
This was probably six,
seven years ago,
but it was a great gig.
Paid good.
And I'm sure there's a lot of cool people in Alaska.
Don't get me wrong.
I met cool people from Alaska.
Strange,
the number of knuckleheads.
It was strange.
It was a very strange place.
It was cool.
Like a lot of cool stuff to do.
They're all like excited to tell you that they all know how to fly planes.
They all,
you know,
they eat Moose Jerky,
they do all this crazy shit,
but then they do really crazy shit.
Like sniff oxycontin and look at you like you're the Weirdo when you don't,
you know,
like that kind of shit.
Like a lot of pill heads up there.
A lot of pill heads.
It's fair northern exposure.
It's not nothing to do there.
Hunt and fuck.
And it wasn't like the mother-in-law of Bristol Palin's baby daddy wasn't she
and busted for selling meth?
Probably.
Yeah,
pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure you know with Scilla Scilla that crazy bitch.
She's with her husband.
Um,
Sarah Pailin husband who was friends with the guy who owned the radio station.
We did an anchorage t dob.
Bob was friends with him.
You played pool with him?
Played Pool with him,
but I didn't know it till years later.
This was six,
seven years ago.
Did he seem like he was gay?
It didn't seem like anything cause he didn't matter to me.
He still had the same kind of like goatee and hair that looked very suspicious,
you know,
like the,
the look that he rocks think his look was like bison the way you say suspicious,
you mean like disingenuous?
He looks very mid nineties.
Very out of place for the year 2006 as it was.
Yeah.
Right.
I was like,
either he's a time traveler out of style.
What do you,
when you do you,
are you,
uh,
the type of guy that,
like when you see a powerful woman with some guy behind her who's not really
talking that much and he just automatically assume that he's a bitch?
Yeah,
yeah.
Right.
Yeah,
and not to be a pig or nothing,
but yeah,
I do.
Yeah,
When I see a really powerful woman,
I want to see what,
what's this guy like?
Is he more powerful or is it less Steadman might be more powerful.
What Oprah's man?
I think he's,
isn't he pretty rich?
Is he on his own?
Yeah,
he's pretty,
can be rich like over rich.
I don't think.
Nobody's Oprah.
Rich.
We got to talk that over it.
Oh yeah,
we talked about kitty.
Now we can talk about over it.
I just love it when Joe talks.
Oprah,
I watched the Oprah show sometimes describes it.
Oh,
do you like her?
No,
I,
yeah,
I think she's interesting.
I don't think she's a bad person.
She's a good person.
She's,
she's doing,
she's spreading positive energy and she's an easy target.
Would you blame your show Rogan or Ellen?
Her or Ellen who didn't Bang Bang Oprah.
I think
Oprah because she was really another pussy,
but she would probably like it.
It's billion dollars,
Allen.
We'll try and be angry at me.
I mean that is assuming that Oprah is truly homosexual or heterosexual rather.
That'd be hot though.
I like it.
You know,
Alan's like,
I don't want this Dick and pick it up over here to take me.
You got a different thing that turns you on buddy.
And he checked it.
Well,
you know,
there's two types of lesbians.
There's lesbians by genetics or lesbians by circumstance and lesbians by life,
you know,
lesbians by abusive men.
And those are the scary ones.
Not Scary but sad I should say.
Sad.
Well I've heard a lot of girls that they just met so many fucking asshole men
from their father all the way down to every fucking guy they've ever attracted
and they're just like,
fuck man,
I need accompaniment,
I needed,
my girls always been there for me and you hug this girl and next thing you know
you're a lesbian.
Right?
Nothing wrong with that man.
Or you know,
I think women are much more open to the idea of experimenting and you know,
and then maybe they find that they like women better and it's something that
most straight men would never do it.
I mean,
even if you're a girl,
you'd have to admit that,
you know,
plus a spectacular boobs.
Yeah.
This rubber dicks.
I'm sure that they're happy with that.
Just dip it in water.
Hot Water.
Get warm.
Shove it in there.
I think it's real.
Dick.
Is it good to show it another guy?
How much sperm that they made today?
Yeah,
like I picture don't show you the dude's your loads.
Yeah.
Unless they're in the business.
Click,
click.
All right.
Air quotes.
Do you send loads?
No,
I took a picture of today's one,
uh,
because I didn't have sex yesterday and I just to show how much came out to do
you want to show one of your friends,
your loads?
I showed it to my girlfriend and she was like,
wow,
that's crazy.
And it is crazy.
And I just going to check a couple of times when,
when,
when you showed it to her,
cause he jerked off on your own.
Is that what it is?
She was at work and I was like,
uh,
like hey fellows is going to show you,
but uh,
it's gay.
Right?
That's gay.
That's worse than showing your poop.
Right.
You need to go to a doctor.
It's just like coming out of your body.
It's a gay cause it's called.
I've never show me pictures of your shit either,
unless they're spectacularly huge.
I had a wraparound porch amount of calm.
It's surprising.
Okay.
Egg whites or something.
I don't know.
Eating healthy,
Taking zinc now.
Any supplements?
Sushi.
The social dude.
There's a lot of zinc out of heavy metals as well.
It'd be careful.
I believe they drove Jeremy Pivot and crazy,
right?
He didn't.
He had to get out of some sort of a show because of that.
What's that?
Mercury.
Mercury overdose.
It's fucking real shit,
man.
I used to,
I used to eat anchovies every week,
ac five,
six cans,
anchovies,
and then I got my blood work done and the doctor said there was arsenic in my
blood.
Not much,
but a little bit.
And I go,
what the fuck?
Someone trying to poison me.
No.
He's like,
no,
it's a heavy metal.
Have you'd be needing a lot of seafood?
And I said,
yeah,
I eat a lot of sardines.
It's like,
don't eat the sardines for awhile.
I'll do another test on the clean.
It's arsenic arsenic from some like that too,
right?
Oceans are so God damn polluted.
Yeah.
There's that gigantic patch of,
of garbage that's floating somewhere in the middle of the Pacific.
It's not just one.
There's a bunch of them and it's underwater.
It's not just on the surface.
There's like a fuck load of it under one end.
There are enormous,
now they're almost the exact size of the United States.
It's habit.
That's crazy.
Used to be the size of Texas and the latest one.
Would they say that it was almost the size of the United States?
That's ridiculous.
Insane.
It's the scariest thing ever and in,
you know what?
All this shit that came from fucking Tokyo was all added to that too,
by the way.
Are from Japan rather.
Yeah.
All that shit that got washed away in the earth,
in the,
in the earthquake,
the tsunami.
That stuff's out at sea.
I mean there's all a lot of fucking debris out at sea.
They're finding houses,
actual full houses floating in the ocean.
Oh,
I'm sure.
And way out there and they've had what,
three seven pluses.
And it's so crazy that someone decided to put a goddamn series of nuclear
reactors on fault lines.
Like it's almost like fault lines on an island.
People were so silly.
It's like daily w the earth could move,
but then again it might not.
It's man's,
you know,
it's when people start to say this God stuff and they said to be like,
look,
look at the,
and you know,
it's like,
no,
there isn't a god.
It's just mother nature of being itself.
And we went and did something stupid,
you know?
Well that is mother nature though.
We are insanely curious and we have this weird desire to test the boundaries and
to try limitations.
Yeah.
We to tame Mother Nature and also to tool off the next new thing to be able to
get power out of this gigantic building that fills up the entire city.
It's just some new me.
Literally,
they're harnessing the power of the fucking sun inside this,
this facility and containing it somehow or another.
The real problem is,
I mean they've,
they've made some,
you know,
some safe guards and shit and make things,
a little bit they can contain situation's a little bit better,
but clearly they didn't think of every possible scenario.
They didn't think of a nine.
Right.
They didn't know.
They didn't think of a nine that rattled for five minutes.
Because when you think of that and you think of a nine,
you have to consider if you're putting out a budget for something,
how often does a nine happened so often that we can't,
we can't appeal.
We can't pay for the worst possible scenario.
We have to pay for a pretty bad one.
But what a colossal fuck up.
It's another reason to get the fuck out of California because there's all sorts
of fault and there's all sorts of fucking reactors.
There's one in Orange County.
Anything over an eight we've got a big problem.
Yeah.
If it's scary shit man.
But you know what?
That's the cost of living somewhere where it's 75 degrees every day.
Yeah.
But it's not 75 degrees every day in Japan.
And I don't know what the deal is over there.
You know what,
I'm not and that's why I don't think the coolest shit.
That's why they do this.
Yeah.
This is another subject that we talked about yesterday on the Corolla show that
this is the exact perfect place geographically as far as like climate,
you can't get any better.
But as far as like the,
the worth of human beings because there's so many of us,
you know the you,
it becomes people becomes less valuable and they become more aggressive toward
each other and more shitty to each other is way more cool people because there's
so many of us because it just sheer numbers.
I mean this podcast is,
is absolute proof of that.
One of the coolest things about this podcast to me is like it reunites mean and,
and,
and like makes me realize how many interesting fucking people I know how many
cool friends I have that can come over and we have these cool conversations and
then this goes out into the Internet and the whole world gets it.
It's like there's not that many people that have,
you know,
Freddy Loc Arts and Sam Tripoli's and all these different characters and Duncan
trussell's and you know,
and,
and Kevin Pereira,
there's all these different cool people and Joey and Ari in their life.
I mean,
there's so many of them,
you know?
And part of that is because we're living in this giant population center and
it's very show big centric.
So you know,
everyone's attracted to this spot.
It's one of the few things that keeps me here.
Really.
I like it.
I mean,
it becomes like a way of life after a while and you really can't leave it
because when I'm outside of Weirdo Ville,
I find that normal people would be extremely weird.
You know what I mean?
Is I find that once and desires of my friends,
when I go back,
when I go back to Arizona and I hang out with some of my friends,
some of them are still have their youth and they still have kids and they have
family,
but they maintain their youth.
The most of them just turned into their parents.
Right.
And it's a really weird thing to me that like they say,
the pressing the apex of their life is over and now it's just kind of like going
through the motions where I still like to think the best is yet to talk with
you.
You have a different career than that.
I haven't much regular career.
You're a guy who sells Buicks,
whatever the fuck you are.
But when people add you on Facebook,
how crazy different do they look like then you us,
you know like,
like,
like people adding,
adding need a Facebook from high school and stuff.
I'm like,
Holy Shit.
That I'm older dads friends now.
Yeah.
Well Pork Fox have to work for living.
Those poor folks are out there grinding visually.
Visually.
They just look like stress 20 or 30 years older.
Look at Obama,
look at what he looks like now as opposed to what you do.
Look at Bush when Bush got into office and then towards the end,
look at Clinton Clinton's whole hair.
Whole head.
Her hair went gray by the time he was out.
I mean that Shit ages you any like extreme stress ages.
Yeah.
Victim,
your stress level compared to a guy with a real job?
It's ridiculously low.
Yeah.
Mine is ridiculously low.
I don't stress about a whole lot to the point where I've gotten,
you know,
I have time to stress all the time now even if it's not important.
I need to stop doing that because your life is easy as fuck.
It's even when my life is hard,
like the difficult shit about my life is all just,
just requires preparation and there's no stress because I actually enjoy doing
it.
Sure.
The real stress comes from something that you don't enjoy doing it,
but it requires an extreme amount of preparation and extreme amount of time and
you put all this effort into something you don't even like and you're just doing
it just for money.
Yeah.
You know like if you're a lawyer and you don't like being a lawyer,
you're just doing it cause there's a lot of money in it will fucking break you.
And I think that's the,
at the end of the day,
that's what brought us all here is we have that child like thing in us that says
I want to do this thing.
I always wanted to do it and then see it through.
Yeah,
you have to be completely child like to believe you could actually pull it off.
I remember when I was a kid,
I was dating this girl,
I was 21 she was a really nice girl and there was Jennifer and she was a
sweetheart and we were both really young and really stupid and you know,
she was just getting out of college and I was a psychopath and her father did
not want her hanging around with maybe she was like,
he's trying to be a comedian.
Oh yeah.
What are the odds that he's going to make it?
Like this kid is not going to,
he's going to be a loser.
And I remember sitting and thinking about going,
wow,
I never even considered that.
Right.
I'm just going to do this,
man.
I'm just going to do this.
Like I'm,
I'm going to do it.
You know what,
if you fail,
what have you do?
One of you felt maybe,
I don't know right now,
I've got to just do this.
I gotta go.
I gotta show and Peabody,
I gotta fucking get,
get some gas in my tank.
I'm not thinking about not doing it,
man.
I might fuck up on my fail.
Yeah,
I'm terrified of being a loser.
Absolutely.
But I'm not going to just sit here and dwell on it.
I'm just,
I'm going to go for it.
Most people would not be a comedian.
They want predictability in their lives and they want their lives to be mapped
out for them.
And it's like I live day to day.
I literally live day to day.
I literally get up and say,
what is today offer?
This is going to be great.
You know,
my girlfriend,
she's a sweetheart,
but she's stressed this all the time.
Always share.
The Sky is falling and all that and I have to tell her pocket,
let it go.
We're all built,
designed,
engineered by the universe and nature and our own personal experiences.
We're all different and we're just fucking different.
And you're not supposed to be a physicist.
You're not supposed to be teaching at Harvard.
You know,
you're not supposed to be working on,
you know,
molecular science and breaking down the university or not.
I'm not supposed to be doing it either.
I'm supposed to be a comedian.
I mean,
it's really simple.
this is what my personality is,
gels the best with.
And you know,
some people's,
it's the most terrifying thing in the world to go on.
I mean,
you know,
we've got shows this weekend,
all in Philadelphia,
one of the wildest fucking towns,
everything's sold out in advance.
We're going to go there as they're going to be fucking crazy.
It's me,
Joey Diaz and Ari were going to be an in that,
that helium in Philly for some people that would be unbelievably terrifying.
The idea that you're going to go there,
there's going to be this packed show of people will anticipating your material,
wanting you to make them a laugh,
paying to see you talk and they're going to be drinking.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
But to a lot of people that,
that idea is horrified.
If you went to any town hall or in the town hall,
when the fuck,
what am I even talking about?
Kinda getting any store and take some guy who was a working behind the counter,
you know,
it was a a cashier and say,
okay,
we're going to uni.
You've got one day to come up with a bunch of shit to say and then you're going
to go on stage in front of these rabid animals and,
and you know,
and,
and some comedy club in Philadelphia.
Right.
That'd be the most terrifying thing in the world.
But for you,
I'm telling you,
as I'm telling you,
you're getting this big smile on the face.
Oh man,
that sounds like fun.
Yeah,
look at you.
You're thinking about it.
That's the thing.
It's like,
yeah,
we were,
you're supposed to be doing this for so long that it's like,
that's super exciting to me.
And it's like,
you know,
I'll meet people,
like,
they'll hang out with you before your show or something.
Be like nervous.
I'm like,
what?
What about,
what about your show tonight and you're not even thinking it.
I wouldn't think about my show until it's time to go to the show.
You know,
people do.
They don't realize that you would get nervous.
It was your first time ever on stage and you'd never done it before.
But once you do it a bunch of times,
it becomes a thing you do.
You get excited,
you mean,
but you know,
you make sure you do your preparation and then you don't get nervous.
Yeah.
Granted there's that fight or flight feeling right before I go to butterflies to
let me know I'm a human and I'm alive.
I've harnessed it and I take that adrenaline and make it happy time instead of,
you know,
and that's like,
I think we talked about last time,
that adrenaline is what prevents you from farting,
sneezing,
having to puke on stage,
shutdown peeing.
And you just go right into fight or flight where you have to be focused,
focused,
focused.
I've never had a stop a show cause I had to pay,
never happy,
never had a poop.
Never had to know.
I'm lactose intolerant,
I can be up there drinking milk and I want to have to stop.
Everything shuts down everything in a strange way to make live in,
isn't it?
It is,
but it's the only way I know in my entire adult life and we're all here on this
west coast hanging on,
trying to make it happen.
Trying to put that fucking entertainment thing together in the perfect way and
they call those fucking pieces fall into place and boom.
Done.
Leave your mark.
Yeah.
Freddie Jacari.
Follow him on Twitter.
Follow me on Twitter at f.
R.
E.
D.
Y not I.
He likes some fucking run of the mill.
Freddy douchebag.
This is f.
That's Freddy Lockhart.
Bitches.
Respect the greatest Morgan Freeman and ice tea impressionists in the world.
Yes.
How about that?
Nice.
Thank you.
Thank you for having [inaudible].
I just said that.
That's true.
You're a hundred percent you're the number one.
No one can fuck with you.
We've got to do some gigs together.
Man.
Was,
I just want to,
Joe Rogan says these kinds of things.
We're going to do some gigs together.
I'd like them.
We've got to fit together.
We've got to go fishing too.
We've got to make it all happen.
Fall Freddie on Twitter.
We'll be back tomorrow.
Same time,
three o'clock.
I don't even know who the fuck are you guys done?
So I have to make some calls.
We got sounds a comedy also.
How's comedy hold tomorrow night at 8:00 PM Friday I'll show up and a,
I'm doing a lot of road gig so I might not be doing it for a while after that.
It might just might this week might be my last one because I can't do next week.
Uh,
Freddy's going to show up and uh,
that's it.
A fleshlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click the link and you get 15% off,
if you enter in the code name Rogan,
when you get to print it off and save a little money,
kind of like my next day.
Fuck yeah.
All right.
Please come out to stand up.
Scottsdale and Scottsdale,
Arizona.
April 21st and 22nd,
I'll be headlining there.
Come out,
stand up Scottsdale,
go stand up scottsdale.com powerful and do you have a website and then go to a,
you have a website and go through with Freddy lockhart.com which will take you
to my Facebook page.
I go to my Facebook page.
It's all now on my fan page.
Powerful,
powerful.
Freddy Lockhart.
Um,
as of today,
there was only a couple of tickets left for,
we added a show Thursday night and a Philly and a helium.
I don't know if they're gone yet,
but if they're not hop on it.
So,
uh,
were there all weekend,
Thursday,
Friday and Saturday.
Everything else is sold out.
Joey has an Ari Shaffir.
It's a full desk squad.
Manas Brian,
because kids are just going to be here shooting loads and taking pictures of it
and a so we'll see you guys tomorrow.
Thank you very much.
Tuned in.
Appreciate it.
Love you bitches.
Thanks later.